GOOD AFTERNOON LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN AND WELCOME TO THE
SENATE VETERANS AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE EARING.
AND I WELCOME YOU ALL AND I'D
LIKE TO BEGIN OUR MEETING.
THE FIRST THING I DO IS HAVE OUR
VETERANS STAND UP AND BE
RECOGNIZED PLEASE STAND.
ARE VETERANS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IN THE CENTER LEVEL THAT'S HOW
WE BEGIN OUR VETERANS COMMITTEE.
EVERY TIME.
THAT'S IT SO.
OF THE USC MARCHING BAND
COULDN'T GET IN THE FRONT DOOR
BUT WE'LL GET HIM NEXT TIME.
ANYWAY -- THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT THOSE WHO SERVED OUR
GREAT COUNTRY -- IN ALL OF YOU
WHO LOVE OUR VETERANS AS WELL
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE I THINK
WE'RE ABOUT READY TO START I
THINK WE MAY HAVE A ROLE OF OF
THE FULL -- FULL AGENDA BUT I
THINK WE MAY HAVE ENOUGH TO HAVE
A FULL A FULL HEARING SHOWS.
MADAM SECRETARY TO CALL THE ROLL.
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ROW [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
WELL.
WE'VE GOT.
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM.
SO.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND BEGIN.
THE THE FIRST ITEM ON THE AGENDA.
WILL BE CENTER LEYVA SB.
THREE TWELVE AND TENDER LABOR
WOULD YOU PRESENT YOUR GUEST AS
WELL PLACE.
AND I THINK THEY'RE BACK IN THE
BACK.
YES WE HAVE A VARIETY OF GAS AND
I WILL LET THEM INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES ONCE WE GET TO THAT
POINT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
ARCHULETA I HAVE TO SAY THAT
WHEN I WAS FIRST ELECTED TO THE
SENATE OF PEOPLE TOLD ME DO NOT
FALL IN LOVE WITH YOUR BILLS.
WELL I FALL IN LOVE WITH SOME OF
MY BILLS AND THIS IS A BILL THAT
I HAVE FALLEN IN LOVE WITH.
BECAUSE THE EFFECTS THAT IT CAN
HAVE AND THE LIVES IT CAN CHANGE
SO WITH THAT I WILL START BY
THANKING YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS BILL AND
IS VERY IMPORTANT MAJOR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
SB THREE TWELVE WOULD REQUIRE
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS CALVET TO
ESTABLISH A COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE VETERANS
SUFFERING FROM POST TRAUMATIC
STRESS DISORDER PTSD.
BUT THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
ACQUIRING AND CARING FOR A
SERVICE DOG.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO NEARLY TWO
MILLION VETERANS THE HIGHEST OF
ANY STATE IN OUR UNION.
THESE BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN
RESTORE LIVES DURING THEIR
MILITARY SERVICE IN SOME CASES
SUFFERED SEVERE TRAUMA THAT
RESULTED IN PTSD. FOR VETERANS
THERE IS A LACK OF ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND THIS
IS MADE REINTEGRATION INTO
NORMAL CIVILIAN LIFE CHALLENGING
FOR THESE VETERANS AND FOR THEIR
FAMILIES.
THE TRAUMA THAT SOME VETERANS
INTER AS A RESULT OF COMBAT
SERVICE HAS ALSO LED TO
INCREASED RATES OF SUICIDE.
SADLY 5220% VETERANS SUFFER FROM
PTSD.
AND ON AVERAGE TWENTY VETERANS
PER DAY.
OR ONE EVERY SIXTY FIVE MINUTES
COMMIT SUICIDE.
THAT IS A RATE ONE AND A HALF
TIMES HIGHER THAN NOT VETERANS.
EARLIER THIS MONTH THREE US
MILITARY VETERANS DIED BY
SUICIDE OVER A SPAN OF FIVE DAYS
ALL IT BE A FACILITIES.
THIS LOSS OF LIFE IS TRAGIC AND
UNACCEPTABLE.
OUR VETERAN COMMUNITY IS
SUFFERING AND IS CRITICAL THAT
WE FIND WAYS TO REDUCE VETERANS
SO SITES.
STUDIES AND NUMEROUS EXAMPLES
SHOW THAT PAIRING VETERANS WITH
SERVICE DOGS HAS A SIGNIFICANT
EFFECT ON REDUCING SYMPTOMS OF
PTSD.
UNFORTUNATELY ACCESSING SERVICE
DOGS CAN BE EXTREMELY DIFFICULT
FOR VETERANS TO TO COSTS.
LACK OF AWARENESS AND LITTLE TO
NO SUPPORT FROM STATE OR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
ALTHOUGH SOME NONPROFITS WORK TO
PAIR VETERANS WITH SERVICE
STOCKS ACROSS HER STATES.
THERE ARE STATE THEIR SOURCES
RESOURCES ARE LIMITED SO MUCH
MORE CAN BE DONE AND MUST BE
DONE.
THIS MEASURE WOULD AWARD GRANTS
TO CERTIFIED VETERANS SERVICE
DOG PROVIDERS TO HELP VETERANS
SUFFERING PTO FROM PTSD WITH THE
COST OF ACQUIRING A SERVICE DOG.
AND PROVIDING TRAINING EQUIPMENT
AND VETS SERVICES.
SB THREE TWELVE WILL ENSURE THAT
VETERANS ARE PROVIDED THE
ASSISTANCE NEEDED TO CARE FOR A
SERVICE DOG.
WITH ME TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OUR
DOCTOR KATHY STRONG FROM USA
STRONG FOR VETERANS.
ANDY MAKE TEA PRESIDENT OF
VETERANS CANINE INTELLIGENCE
ACADEMY.
AND I'M NOT SURE.
ARE YOU WENDY HI WENDY WE HAVE
WINDY CLARK JOHNSON FROM CANINE
COMPANIONS FOR INDEPENDENCE.
AND YOU JUST INTRODUCE YOURSELF
AND I FORGOT.
BRUCE PITTMAN IS HERE AS WELL AS
WELL AS MANY SERVICE DOGS AS YOU
CAN ALL SEE SO I WILL TURN IT
OVER TO MY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GO RIGHT AHEAD KATIE STRONG --
I'M A MARATHON RUNNER A MOM
ACOSTA COLLEGES AND AN
EDUCATIONAL CYCLE -- I AM HERE --
FOR THE VETERANS AND BECAUSE
THEY HAVE INSPIRED ME SO MUCH --
I WAS DOING RESEARCH A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO AFTER MY FATHER PASSEDAWAY -- ON WORLD WAR ONE WORLD
WAR TWO AND THE KOREAN WAR ARE
JUST TRYING TO FIND OUT WHAT MY
FATHER GRANDFATHER HAD GONE
THROUGH BUT THEIR EXPERIENCES
WERE LIKE.
AND I RAN ACROSS AN ARTICLE THAT
TALKED ABOUT THE TWENTY TWOS.
I'M A CIVILIAN AND I NEVER HEARD
ABOUT IT AND I WAS QUITE SHOCKED
I CAN BELIEVE THAT -- THAT WAS
OCCURRING AND I COULDN'T BELIEVE
ALSO THAT THE REST OF THE
CIVILIAN POPULATION THAT I KNEW
OF DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT THIS EITHER.
I CAN UNDERSTAND WHY IT'S NOT ON
THE TV NEWS EVERY NIGHT -- I
TALKED TO MY COLLEAGUES MY
FRIENDS MANY PEOPLE AND NOBODY
KNEW ABOUT IT.
AND I REALIZE THAT -- THAT
NEEDED TO BE CHANGED BECAUSE
THEY WERE NOT AWARE ABOUT THIS
PROBLEM THEN HOW ARE YOU GOING
TO HELP TO CHANGE IT ONCE WERE
ALL WHERE THEN WE CAN REALLY
WORK TOGETHER TO MAKE CHANGE.
SO YOU MIGHT THINK I'M TOO SO
MUCH IS SHORT OF A PICNIC BUT IN
ORDER TO WORK RAISE AWARENESS I
RAN ACROSS UNITED STATES FROM
OREGON TO WASHINGTON DC. TWENTY
FIVE TO THIRTY FIVE MILES A DAY
AND ALONG THE WAY I SPOKE TO A
NEWS -- TELEVISION NEWS -- CASTS
ARE WAS AMUSED AT CAL SEVEN
CHANNEL FOUR A FOX NEWS I SPOKE
TO NEWSPAPERS JUST TRYING TO GET
THE WORD OUT TRYING TO
COMMUNICATE WHAT WAS GOING ON IN
AND I WANTED TO TALK JUST A
MINUTE ABOUT MY EXPERIENCE OF
RUNNING WHERE I ALMOST GAVE UP --
I RAN FACING THE TRAFFIC AS
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO DO -- AS A
RUNNER AND ARM JUST TO STAY SAFE
AND THEN -- TRAFFIC COMING OUT
ME ON FOR ABOUT A HUNDRED MILES --
I WAS REALLY START TO GET TOO
CONCERNED BECAUSE I WAS
LITERALLY WITHIN ARM'S REACH OF
BIG RIGS WHEELS I CAN REACH OUT
AND I COULD LITERALLY TOUCH THEM
BECAUSE THERE IS A STILL SMALL
SLIVER OF ROAD THAT I COULD.
RUN ACROSS AND I JUST STARTED
THINK YOU KNOW MAN I I DON'T
THINK I'M GOING TO MAKE IT YOU
KNOW I I THINK THIS IS JUST
REALLY RISKY.
I THOUGHT FOR A MINUTE YOU KNOW
I WONDER VETERANS EVER SAY THAT
I DON'T KNOW IF I'M GOING TO
MAKE IT THIS IS REALLY RISKY.
I THOUGHT ABOUT THEM AND I
REMEMBER THE REASON WHY I
STARTED OUT IN THE FIRST PLACE.
AND THEN I REALIZED YEAH AT THIS
VERY MOMENT SERVICEMEN AND WOMEN
ARE OVERSEAS THEY'RE FIGHTING
FOR ME THEY'RE FIGHTING FOR MY
COME MY COUNTRY AND THEY'RE NOT
GIVING INTO FEAR THEY'RE NOT
QUITTING.
AND SO I DECIDED NO MATTER WHAT
FOR THEM I'M GONNA FINISH OR DIE
TRYING.
AND SO I DID FINISH AND I'M HERE
AND I'M TRYING TO FIGHT FOR IT
FOR THIS BILL FOR THEM BECAUSE
IT'S SO HELPFUL -- YOU WENT OVER
SOME OF THE FACTS -- THE SUICIDE
RATE IF YOU LOOK AT IT A YEARLY
NUMBERS OVER SEVEN THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED PER YEAR.
AND I'M APPOINTED WITH
PERSONALLY OF SOME FAMILIES NOW --
MANY FAMILIES NOW THAT HAVE LOST
THEIR SENSE TO TO SUICIDE.
THE CURRENT TREATMENT FOR PTSD
IS MEDICATION AND PSYCHOTHERAPY
THIS PROVIDES ITS BENEFIT FOR
ALMOST ABOUT 70% BUT THE OTHER
30%.
DON'T BENEFIT FROM THIS
COMBINATION THE TWO OF THEM IS
ALL THAT THEY HAVE OPTION TO
THEIR VERY RARELY ARE OFFERED
ANY OTHER OPTIONS.
BUT THE THIRD OPTION IS -- YOU
KNOW IF THE SOONEST THEIR ARMS
SERVICE DOG -- THE 30% OF THEIR
OFFER THIS THIRD OPTION THAT
WOULD BE VERY BENEFICIAL THE
SERVICE ON TREATMENT HAS A
REALLY HIGH RATE OF SUCCESS --
AT DECREASING SUICIDALITY AND
INCREASING LIFE SATISFACTION --
THERE IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS THERE'S BEEN SOME
EMPIRICAL STUDIES THAT VALIDATED
THIS AS A TREATMENT -- RECENT
STUDIES FROM THE PURDUE-UNIVERSITY OUR DEPARTMENT OF
ANIMAL SCIENCE DID A
PHYSIOLOGICAL STUDY ON CORTISOL
LEVELS.
WHERE'S ALL LEVELS BEING IN THE
HOME ON THAT THE BODY SECRETES
WHEN IT'S UNDER HIGH CRIME THIS
CHRONIC STRESS.
AND THE CORTISOL LEVELS WERE
DECREASED SIGNIFICANTLY IN THIS
RESEARCH STUDY -- SO WITH -- DR --
HERE IS ALSO FROM THAT -- ANIMAL
SCIENCE -- DEPARTMENT SHE'S ALSO
WORKED WITH THE CENTER FOR HUMAN
ANIMAL BOND.
AND SHE FOUND THAT COMPARED TO
INDIVIDUALS ON THE WAIT LIST FOR
SERVICE DOGS THOSE WHO ACTUALLY
HAD SERVICE DOGS HAD THE
SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER CYCLE
SOCIAL HEALTH INCREASED
EMOTIONAL HEALTH.
INCREASE SOCIAL AND WORK AND
SCHOOL FUNCTIONING.
AND SHE ALSO WAS WORKING WITH
THE STUDY ON CORTISOL LEVELS AND
THAT IS A VERY IMPORTANT FINDING --
FINALLY -- I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH
YOU KNOW ABOUT SERVICE DOGS --
BUT THEY ARE SET APART
PROMOTIONAL AND OF SIR A
MOTIONAL SUPPORT DOGS AND CATS.
BECAUSE NOT ONLY ARE THEY
TRAINED IN THE SEVEN BASIC
COMMANDS THEY ARE ALSO TRAINED
TO DO -- TASKS SPECIFIC TO EACH
INDIVIDUAL BET WHAT THEY NEED IN
PARTICULAR.
AND THERE ARE OVER A HUNDRED
FOURTY TASKS THAT THEY CAN
PERFORM.
A FEW OF THEM THAT ARE SPECIFIC
TO PTSD.
AND ANY VETERAN.
WITH A SERVICE DOG CAN ATTEST TO
THE FACT THAT THEIR DOG IS A
LOYAL CARING AND DEDICATED FORCE.
THAT GIVES THEIR LIFE FOR THEM --
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN THEIR THERE
FOR THEM THE BOND TOWARDS --
THEIR SERVICE DOG AND THE
SERVICE DOGS BY TOWARDS A
VETERAN IS UNDER MY UNDENIABLY
BENEFICIAL AND LIFESAVING.
AND SO I'M HERE TODAY -- TO ASK
YOU.
YEAH.
WE WANT TO GIVE EACH.
SO YEAH.
SHORT IT WILL COME BACK OKAY
YEAH ONE I AM ABLE TO HAVE.
RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO I'M I'M JUST HERE
TO PRESENT THAT INFORMATION AND
I'D BE HONORED AND THANKFUL IF
THE MEMBERS -- HERE WOULD BE
ABLE TO PASS THE SENATE BILL --
ISABEL THAT'LL WILL ASSIST
VETERANS AND LEAD TO MORE
FULFILLING LIVES AND IT
ABSOLUTELY WILL SAVE LIVES FOR
MANY YEARS TO COME.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
VERY BRIEFLY.
WE SAVE LIVES EVERY DAY.
IF WE PREVENT THE TWENTY TWO I
HAVE DOGS AND VETERANS THAT COME
TO ME ON A DAILY BASIS THEY
START TRAINING THE DAY THEY SHOW
UP [inaudible]
IT'S WORKING.
THE FURTHER WHEN THE IN OKAY.
MY NAME IS WHEN THE CLOCK
JOHNSON I'M HERE SO --
REPRESENTING KEENING COMPANIONS
FOR INDEPENDENCE FOR THE LARGEST
NONPROFIT.
ORGANIZATION THAT PLACES DOGS IN
HOMES ON A VARIETY DISABILITIES
FREE OF CHARGE TO THE PERSON WHO
RECEIVES THEM.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED TEAMS
WORKING NATIONWIDE THIS IS NOT A
NATION WIDE PROGRAM.
OF OF THAT THERE'S JUST UNDER
THREE HUNDRED GRADUATE TEAMS ARE
SPECIFICALLY WORKING WITH
VETERANS AND A VARIETY OF TASKS
AS THE DOCTOR EXPLAINED.
THESE PUPPIES ARE ALL THROUGH
THE PROGRAM THIS LITTLE GIRL
HERE IS ACTUALLY IN TRAINING SO
SHE'S LEARNING INSPIRING TO BE
WHAT'S RIGHT IN FRONT OF YOU --
THEY START WITH A THEIR WITH A
PERSON -- FROM THE TIME THEY'RE
BORN ACTUALLY I HAVE USE IN MY
HOME ALL THE TIME.
WE RAISE THEM AND THEN WE TURN
THEM IN WHEN THEY GO THE
PROFESSIONAL TRAINING.
THAT'S GREAT IT'S WONDERFUL I AM
NOT A VETERAN BUT I COME FROM A
FAMILY OF STE OF VETERANS MY DAD
GRANDPARENTS BOTH OF MY SISTERS
ARE VETERANS.
I DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT SERVICE DOGS
I KNEW ABOUT THE PROBLEMS THAT
HAPPENED WHEN THEY CAME HOME I
KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH MY
SISTER BUT AS A PERSON WHO IS
NOW BEEN VOLUNTEERING FOR TEN
YEARS.
INTEL I BECAME PART OF KING AND
COMPANIONS I DID NOT KNOW.
AND SO THAT IS A HUGE PIECES THE
SENATOR MENTIONED THE OUT
REACHES OUT THERE WHAT I WILL
TELL YOU OF THE VETERANS THAT I
MEET.
THEY SAY [inaudible]
THAT'S GREAT.
I'M NOT DISABLED ENOUGH I'M NOT
WANTED ENOUGH PLEASE GIVE THE
STOCK TO SOMEONE WHO NEEDS IT.
AND THEY NEED IT SO I AM TOTALLY
HONORED BECAUSE AS A PUPPY
RAISER AT THE GREAT HISTORY WE
HAVE AS OUR DOGS GO FROM YELLOW
COAT. TO A BLUE COAT AS
WIMBERLEY IS HERE THE ENERGIES
BRUCE AND GRADUATE TEAM I'M IS
SERVICE DOG WEMBLEY.
HELLO -- I'M BRUCE PITTMAN I MAY --
RECENT RETIRED -- MARINE -- AND
I RECEIVED WEMBLEY IN SEPTEMBER --
WHEN WHEN I WERE A PART THE
FIRST CLASS OF -- PTSD GRADUATES
OUT OF CANINE COMPANIONS.
AND THERE WERE THERE WERE FOUR
OF US THAT TO GRADUATE WITH DOGS --
IN THAT PROGRAM AND HE HAS BEEN
ABSOLUTE LIFE CHANGING.
PART OF MY MY FAMILY AT THIS
POINT.
HE AND I GO EVERYWHERE TOGETHER.
PRIOR TO HAVING WEMBLEY -- I
WILL I WOOD CICHLID MYSELF I
WOULD NOT GO OUT ANYWHERE UNLESS
I WAS WITH MY WIFE -- I HAVE
REFERRED TO AS MY SERVICE DOG
PRIOR TO LEARNING ABOUT SERVICE
DOGS HAVE -- AND AND REALLY
SHE'S THE ONLY REASON WHY I
WOULD GO OUT WAS IF I WAS WITH
HER AND I ARE OTHERWISE WOULD
NOT TO GO OUT IN PUBLIC -- AND
WEBLEY HAS HAS ENABLED ME TO DO
THAT ON MY OWN AND AND IT HAS
BEEN A TREMENDOUS ASSET.
AND HIS HIS SKILLS HE NOT ONLY
DOES THE HELP ME WITH THE THE
PTSD PIECES OF OF OF MY LIFE BUT
HE ALSO DOES A LOT OF MOBILITY
THINGS FOR ME AS WELL -- HE'S
ABLE TO RETRIEVE THINGS PICK
THINGS UP HE CAN OPEN DOORS --
AND HE'S HE'S JUST BEEN A
TREMENDOUS ASSET YEAH I'VE HAD
SINCE SEPTEMBER AND HE'S
COMPLETELY CHANGED MY LIFE.
IT'S BEEN THE BEST THING THAT
HAS HAPPENED TO ME SINCE MY
THIRTY FOUR YEARS OF SERVICE IN
THE MARINE CORPS AND AND MY
RETIREMENT AND SUPPORT THAT.
THAT I HAVE RECEIVED FROM THE VA
YOU KNOW THE VA'S WORKING HARDER
A LOT OF VETERANS OUT THERE.
BUT A SERVICE DOG.
IS BY FAR THE MOST -- ENABLING.
TOOL TO A SERVICE MEMBER --
CAN'T SPEAKA MORE HIGHLY ABOUT
THE PROGRAM CANINE COMPANIONS --
PROVIDING FREE DOG -- TO TO LET
NEED THEM -- AND ABSOLUTELY LIFE
CHANGING -- THIS PROGRAM IS
INVALUABLE TO TO OUR SERVICE
MEMBERS AND THEY DON'T GET MUCH
OF A VOICE THAT'S WHY I'M HERE
AND ONE MAKE SURE THAT.
THE YOU'LL HAVE A CHANCE TO TO
TO TO TALK TO ME AND OTHER
VETERANS IN THAT HAVE DOGS AND
CAN EXPRESS TO YOU.
THE IMPORTANCE OF THEM.
THE VA DOES NOT RECOGNIZE --
PTSD -- SERVICE DOGS -- DATE SO
THE VA WILL PROVIDE.
FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR SERVICE
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A PHYSICAL
DISABILITY.
IF IT'S A MENTAL DISABILITY.
THE VA DOES NOT CURRENTLY
RECOGNIZE THAT -- AND THAT IS A
SIGNIFICANT BURDEN TO PEOPLE OF
ANY OTHER CHALLENGE FINANCALLY --
I DON'T SUFFER FROM THAT -- MY
THIRTY FOUR YEARS OF SERVICE I'M
I'M PRETTY WELL OFF.
AND CAN AFFORD TO PAY FOR A PET
A DOG BUT THE VET BILLS ALONE
CAN BE ENOUGH -- TO PUT A A A
VETERAN IN FINANCIAL STRAITS.
AND THE VA WILL NOT COVER THAT --
AND CANINE COMPANIONS.
NOW THEY'VE GIVEN ME THIS
BEAUTIFUL ANIMAL.
ESTIMATE TO BE ABOUT FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A DOG TO TRAIN
THEM -- THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO
PROVIDE ME WITH FINANCIAL
SUPPORT NICE MY BURDEN AND I AS
AS THE HANDLER -- TO TO PAPERS
VET BILLS A FEEDING A AND ANY
MEDICAL REQUIREMENTS THANK YOU
BRUCE YES -- THE CENTER LEYVA
WANT YOU TO GO AEAD AND INVITE
WHOEVER ELSE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
ON BEHALF OF THE BILL LET'S
BRING THEM UP.
ANYONE ELSE YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK
ON BEHALF OF THE BILL.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION AND SO
WE'LL GO BACK TO CLOSING GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AMOS AT THREE
WITH THREE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS.
REPRESENTING AMERICAN GI FORM OF
CALIFORNIA AND VETS DEPARTMENT
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA'S.
COUNTY BETWEEN SERVICE OFFICERS.
CALIFORNIA STATE MANDERS
[inaudible]
VETERANS COUNCIL.
PHONE SUPPORT IS LET'S JUST.
AND IF I MAY UM I'VE BEEN OUT OF
THE ARMY FOR TEN YEARS NOW -- I
DID TWO COMBAT TOURS -- WHEN I
WENT TO THE VA -- APPROXIMATELY
A YEAR AFTER DISCHARGE OF
SERVICE -- I JUST WANTED A
SERVICE DOG I WENT IN AND I
ASKED HIM FOR HIS SERVICE DOG.
THEY SAID NO BUT WE CAN GIVE YOU
MEDICATION.
MY GOD THANK YOU WELCOME HOME
GENTLEMAN WELCOME HOME.
AS ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL YOU'RE WELCOME TO COME TO
THE MICROPHONE [inaudible]
YES MA'AM.
RIGHT US ARMY I THINK EVERYBODY
HERE IS US ARMY RIGHT.
WELL.
THE SIZE.
OF THE SITE.
ANYWAY AND THAT.
MIGHT HAVE SOMETHING HERE FOR
SENATE NAVY AND MARINE THAT'S
RIGHT OR WRONG I'M IN.
INTO IT OF TESTIMONY TESTIFYING.
RIGHT SO AMERICAN VETERANS WERE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
IT'S NOT CENTER LEYVA YOU'RE
WELCOME TO CLOSE.
HAVE MOVED THE BILL.
THANK YOU -- THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU CENTER
LABOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AS A MILITARY VETERAN
MYSELF IT IT -- IT WARMS MY
HEART THAT THIS IS ACTUALLY
GOING TO GO THROUGH AND AT IN
KERN COUNTY WE HAVE THE WE NEED
HERE IS FINE REPLIED HOMES FOR
DOUBLE AMPUTEES AND AND AND OF
COURSE PHYSICAL DISABILITIES.
BUT WE ALSO STARTED A VIDEO TOUR
IS ONE OF OUR VETERANS STARTED
WHEN HE WAS DONE PROGRAM WHERE
THEY GET DOGS AT THE POUND AND
THEY DO THIS TRAINING AND THEY
PLACE SUCCESSFULLY OVER SIXTY
FIVE DOGS WITH VETERAN SO WHEN
YOU SEE THESE VETERANS.
AND OUT IN THE COMMUNITY THAT
HAVE PTSD THAT ARE NOW GOING TO
FOOTBALL GAMES AND PUBLIC EVENTS.
BECAUSE THE DOG AXES A PROTECT
INTO OR AID.
THE DOCKING FEEL THE PERSON
GETTING AGITATED OR GETTING AND
AND IT NERVOUS OR WHATEVER THE
ISSUE IS AND THE DOG ACTS AS A
BARRIER TO KEEP I DON'T SEE
PEOPLE WAY NOT IN A VICIOUS WAY
BUT JUST.
STANDS IN FRONT OF THE THIS THE
WHEN DID INDIVIDUAL THAT WE HAVE
FOR THE VETERAN THAT WE HAVE.
AND THEN ALSO AS A COMMUNIST
ALREADY AND YOU'LL SEE SOMEBODY
SITTING IN THE STANDS AT A
FOOTBALL GAME AND YOU KNOW THE
CROWD ERUPTS IN CHEERS AND THING
AND ALL THIS AND THE DOG PUT
THIS POND IS.
ON HIS LAP YOU KNOW AND AND THE
VETERAN PETS A DOG AND IT'S IT
IT DOES REALLY WORK IN THEM.
I'VE TALKED TO SEVERAL OF OUR
VETERANS IN OUR COMMUNITY AND IT
DOES WORK AND IN IT IS A GREAT
ALTERNATIVE TO MEDICATION WHICH
IS NOT VERY BENEFICIAL TO SOME
OF OUR VETERANS.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I'D
LIKE TO MOVE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENT.
OF CENTER LABOR AND WALKING WITH
LOW.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT WE ALL
TALK ABOUT DOING SOMETHING FOR
VETERANS WE ALL TALK ABOUT
WANTING TO HELP AND SOMETIMES IT
CAN SEEM A LITTLE UNWIELDY BUT
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS AND SO
MANY ISSUES. TO ME THIS SEEMS
LIKE SOMETHING THAT WE CAN ALL
DO WE CAN ALL PARTICIPATE IN
YOU'VE HEARD EXCELLENT TESTIMONY
ON HOW THESE DOGS CAN BE LIFE
CHANGING.
OR THINK THE GENTLEMAN WHO SPOKE
IN SUPPORT AND I THINK HE
EXEMPLIFIED EXACTLY WHY WE NEED
THIS BILL WE CAN'T JUST CONTINUE
TO PRESCRIBE MEDICATIONS TO OUR
VETERANS WHEN THERE'S A BETTER
WAY WHEN WE CAN HAVE A SERVICE
DOG WE CAN HAVE AN ANIMAL.
AND REALLY IT'S INCUMBENT ON ALL
OF US WHO DIDN'T SERVE WE ENJOY
THE FREEDOM THAT WE ENJOY
BECAUSE OF OUR VETERANS AND IF
WE CAN'T FIND A WAY TO HELP THEM
COMMON TRANSITION BACK AND HAVE
A SUCCESSFUL LIFE.
I THINK THE SB THREE TWELVE GOES
A LONG WAY IN MAKING THAT HAPPEN.
OUR FREEDOM ISN'T FREE AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE WE DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO HELP OUR
PATRONS SO.
RESPECTFULLY AYE ASPIRIN AYE
VOTE AND I THINK ALL OF MY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THE TO A
GET AND THE FOUR LEGGED ONES --
AND I WOULD ALSO SAY THAT FOR
MOST OF US WHO ARE NOT ANY OF US
WERE DOG LOVERS.
I KNOW HOW MUCH WE HAVE TWO DOGS
AND I KNOW HOW MUCH JOY THEY
BRING TO US BUT WHEN THEY CAN
ACTUALLY HELP CHANGE SOMEONES
LIFE THAT'S HUGE SO RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- SECTOR CALL
FOR GROWTH.
SENATE BILL THREE TWELVE TO PASS
BUT FIRST REFERRED PERFORATIONS
ARCHULETA.
HI ARCHULETA I GREW.
GROUP I HER TADO.
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I ROTH ROUGH I NUMBER
[inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
WILK I THE ROOM.
AND WE'RE GONNA HOLD OPEN -- TO
GET THE OTHER APPROACH THANK YOU
AND CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE SO WHAT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
I SEE SENATOR SOON IN THE
AUDIENCE WHO. TWENTY CALENDAR
YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY.
THEIR MOTION MODE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
GOT IT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
A CONSENT CALENDAR DO PASSED THE
FIRST REFER TO RE REFER TO
PREPARATIONS WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS CONSENT
ARCHULETA.
HI ARCHULETA I GREW [inaudible]
RICARDO.
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I ROCK.
I NUMBER.
WILK.
WILK FIVE DOES NOT BETWEEN THE
HOTEL ROOM AND FOR THE RECORD
THAT THAT WAS.
ONE TWO YEAH.
THE RIGHT RESEARCH [inaudible]
ONE TWO AND TEN YEARS A RED HOLD
THE ROLE OF ANOTHER.
YEAH.
HOLDEN ROLE OPEN [inaudible]
AND OUR NEXT.
BOTTOM SENATOR STONE.
AND PLEASE YOUR BILL.
SB THREE SIX FOUR GO AHEAD MAKE
YOUR PRESENTATION THANK YOU ON A
ROLL CHAIR ARE TO LET AND
MEMBERS I AM VERY HAPPY TO
PRESENT SB.
THREE SIXTY FOUR A PROBLEM THAT
IS CURRENTLY PLAGUING CALIFORNIA
IS OUR AMOUNT OF VETERANS WHO
ARE HOMELESS.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIA HAD TEN THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX
HOMELESS VETERANS EQUATING TO
ALMOST 30% OF THE NATION'S TOTAL
HOMELESS VETERAN POPULATION.
VETERANS OF SACRIFICE SO MUCH
FOR OUR COUNTRY AND RETURN LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS
NEED TO DO.
EVERYTHING IN THEIR POWER TO
HELP THEM SUCCEED.
THERE IS NO SINGLE SOLUTION
THAT'S GOING TO SOLVE THIS
CRISIS REASONS FOR THE LARGE
NUMBER OF HOMELESS VETERANS ARE
NUMEROUS AND VERY COMPLEX. TO
THE BIGGEST FACTORS ARE THE
EXTREME SHORTAGE OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND A LIVABLE INCOME.
SB THREE SIXTY FOUR ATTEMPTS TO
ADDRESS THESE PROBLEMS OF
VETERANS FACED BY DOING THE
FOLLOWING.
FIRST SB THREE SIXTY FOUR WILL
CAP THE PROPERTY TAXES ON THE
PRIMARY RESIDENCE OF AN
HONORABLY DISCHARGED VETERAN
OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY FIVE
SECOND.
IT EXEMPTS THE PROPERTY TAX ON
ALL 1100% DISABLED VETERANS
LIVING IN THEIR PRIMARY
RESIDENCE. TWELVE OTHER STATES
ALREADY HONOR THE VETERANS WITH
FULL PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTIONS
LET'S MAKE CALIFORNIA THE NEXT
TO DO SO.
SB THREE SIXTY FOUR PROVIDES A
BASIC STEP IN HELPING OUR
VETERAN COMMUNITY.
BY EXPANDING THE CURRENT
PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION AND
CURRENT REACH OF THE LAW
CALIFORNIA'S HONORING THE
SACRIFICES OF OUR VETERANS AND
PROVIDED THEM WITH A WAY FOR
THEM TO SUCCESSFULLY STAY IN
THEIR HOMES.
THIS BILL IS A REPEAT OF SB. FOR
WHICH PASSED UNANIMOUSLY OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE LAST YEAR.
WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE MY TWO WITNESSES
MISTER CHAIRMAN DAVID BERRGAN A
THIRTY YEAR RETIRED MARINE.
AND ALSO MANDATE MOUNTAIN AS AN
ARMY VETERAN.
DESERVE FOR HER.
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN -- MY MEANS DAVID
BERRIGAN I'M SORRY MAJOR UNITED
STATES MARINE CORPS RETIRED.
I RETIRED IN. TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
ONE NIGHT WHILE JUST BEFORE I
RETIRE MY RETIREMENT I WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH THE STAGE FOR
THROAT CANCER.
BECAUSE I GOT EXPOSED TO ARRANGE --
TO DEPLETED YOUR IRATE.
DEPLETED.
URANIUM WHILE IN IRAQ.
THAT IS TO RADIATE YOUR CANCER
AREA WHICH THEN.
DAMAGE THE ARTERIES IN MY HEART.
SO THEN I HAD THREE STENTS BUT
AND WITH ALL THAT SAID -- IT
MADE ME A STRONGER PERSON THAT
FOR WHAT I AM TODAY I OWN A IN
OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH AND SAFETY
COMPANY INTO MACULA CALIFORNIA.
AND I ALSO HAVE A NONPROFIT
TRAINING AND EDUCATING
TRANSITIONING VETERANS TO GET
INTO THE SAFETY BUSINESS OR BE
SAFETY PROFESSIONALS -- THE
TRANSITION TO CIVILIAN LIFE.
IN ADDITION I'M THE FORMER
SENIOR VICE COMMANDER THE VFW
LOCAL VFW.
FORTY NINE AND I'M THE VETERAN
LIAISON TO THE CITY OF MARIETTA
TO MACULA GIVE YOU ALL THAT
INFORMATION.
BECAUSE ALL TOO OFTEN WITHIN THE
VFW AND WITHIN MY NONPROFIT I
HAVE A TON OF VETERANS THAT.
YOU KNOW WE LIVE IN THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL STATE AND IN THE
UNITED STATES I THANK YOU KNOW
I'M FROM ARIZONA ORIGINALLY.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT THEY'RE
THEY'RE OLD OTHER CONCERN ALWAYS
IS THEY JUST CAN'T AFFORD IT.
WE HAVE 1100% DISABLED VETERANS
WITH WITHIN OUR OUR RANKS.
DAY.
THEY'RE ONE PAYCHECK AWAY FROM
BEING HOMELESS.
BEING THE VETERAN LIAISON TO TWO
OF THE CITIES ALL TOO OFTEN I
GET CALLED OUT [inaudible]
TO ATTEND.
WITH SOME OF THE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE WE HAVE
VETERANS ARE LIVING UNDERNEATH
THE BRIDGE.
AND WHEN ASKED HOW THEY GOT
THERE THEY JUST SAID WHICH IS
JUST. ONE PAYCHECK AWAY AND I
JUST NEVER COULD CATCH UP.
AND UNFORTUNATELY IN THOSE
COUPLE CIRCUMSTANCES THERE 100%
DISABLED VETS.
SO THEY GET THE VETERAN BENEFIT.
WHATEVER THAT MIGHT BE.
I CAN TELL YOU THE THE BENEFIT
THAT WE RECEIVED.
IS NOTHING TO BE ABLE TO SUSTAIN
OURSELVES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL.
WHICH HAS YOU KNOW MY I WOULD
VOTE FOR ABSOLUTELY VOTE FOR IT
WOULD DO NOTHING MORE THAN HELP
US ALL.
THE BILL THE TO PROSPER IN THE
BI<c.cyan> MOST BEAUTIFUL STATE IN</c>
THE UNITED STATES.
THANK YOU DAVID THANK YOU.
FOR THANK YOU RANK HAS ITS
PRIVILEGES.
IT'S A STEP TOWARD HER SERGEANT
MAJOR I WAS A STAFF SERGEANT.
MY NAME'S MANNY MONTONEROS AND
I'M HONORED TO BE HERE SO THANK
YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMAN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
TO SHARE A FEW MINUTES.
MY BACKGROUND.
I'M A COMBAT WOUNDED VIETNAM
VETERAN I WAS WOUNDED IN JANUARY.
EIGHTH NINETEEN SIXTY NINE WHEN
MY TANK GOT HIT BY THREE ROCKET
PROPELLED GRENADES.
RIGHT ON THE CAMBODIAN BORDER.
I DID NOT WALK FOR A WHOLE YEAR.
BUT ONCE I GOT OUT OF THE ARMY.
HEARING THE FOLKS TALK BEFORE US
ON THE SERVICE DOGS I WENT
THROUGH A VERY TROUBLED MARRIAGE
OBVIOUSLY -- MY FIRST WIFE
DIVORCED ME AND I DIDN'T THINK
I'D EVER REMARRY CAM I MET A
WONDERFUL WOMAN.
WE'VE BEEN MARRIED NOW THIRTY
FIVE YEARS HAVE FOUR KIDS.
BUT THE PROBLEM'S THE ISSUES THE
CHALLENGES THAT VETERANS FACE
BACK WHEN WE WERE IN VIETNAM.
YOU WILL REMEMBER SENATOR --
THEY DIDN'T EVEN HAVE A NAME FOR
PTSD BACK THEN IT WAS THEY
THOUGHT WE WERE CRAZY.
I HAVE FOUND TIME NOW TO FORM OF
FIVE OH ONE C. THREE CALLED
FRUITFUL FUTURES PROJECT.
I AM A MEMBER OF THE GODDESS
IT'S CATHOLIC BUSINESS
ORGANIZATION I CULTURE INVENT
CALL THE MAN A CHARACTER IT'S
BOY SCOUT FUND RAISER.
I SUPPORT THE AMERICAN LEGION
I'M ON THE BOARD THE VETERAN
BUSINESS ALLIANCE.
AND I'M HERE TO TELL YOU THAT
THERE'S NO GREATER HONOR AND
REMEMBER IT'S REMEMBRANCE OF
THOSE FOLKS.
THAT HAVE SERVED AND GIVEN THEIR
ALL.
I'VE SERVED ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS FOR CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL OF ORANGE COUNTY I WAS
ON THE EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE WHEN
WE MERGED WITH YOU SEE I I
WORKED THE HOMELESS SHELTER AND
SANTANA.
AND I CAN'T BEGIN TO TELL YOU
WHEN I WEAR MY U. S. ARMY CAPT
TWENTY FIFTH INFANTRY DIVISION.
HOW MANY?
ELDERLY FOLKS MEN AND WOMEN COME
UP TO ME AND SAY I SERVED I
SERVED.
IN HERE WE TAKE THEIR ID WE GIVE
MATALE.
A MATT THAT'S BEEN LYSOL BEEN
WIPED OFF AND THAT'S THEIR HOME
FOR THE EVENING.
PEOPLE THAT HAVE HAD HOMES THAN
THAT HAVE LOST HIM -- OF NEVER
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY SO I'M HERE
TO SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION I
THINK IT'S HONORABLE I THINK
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
AND WHEN YOU GO TO SLEEP TONIGHT
YOUR HEAD HIT SAID COMFORTABLE
PILLOW.
REMEMBER THOSE THAT EIGHTY CAN
FORD THANK YOU -- I REALLY
APPRECIATE.
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR SERVICE
THE COMING BEFORE US LIKE THIS
SO LET'S GO AHEAD AND FIND OUT
WHERE THE SPORT LIES -- ANYONE
WOULD LIKE -- TO VOICE YOUR
SUPPORT PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE ON SB THREE SIXTY
FOUR A MAJOR NUMBER YOU HAVE
MORAN WITH THEIR AND READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENT THE RETIRED
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S AFFECT
WORKERS FOR THE UNITED STATES
BUT BUSINESS ALLIANCE THE STRONG
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DRAKE ME WHAT UNITED STATES
VETERAN BUSINESS ALLIANCE I
SUPPORT THIS BILL 1100%.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CENTERS I'M DOING
GOFFMAN FIRST VICE PRESIDENT FOR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL OF
VIETNAM VETERANS OF AMERICA AND
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS GARY ROSS AND THE
AMERICAN LEGION AND CALIFORNIA
AMERICAN VETERANS AMERICANS
RENDON SUPPORT THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE RAIN POSSUM ERICA VETERANS
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU. THREE BRAVE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA STATE
COMMANDERS ATKINS COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL -- I HAVE A MOTION
WITH THE BILL [inaudible]
COMMENTS [inaudible]
ANYONE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WE HAVE WHAT -- I'M SORRY THAT'S
OKAY.
SENATOR GOING THE WRONG MISTER
CHAIR.
A CENTER STONE EYES TWENTY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR AND BRINGING
THIS PHENOMENAL BILL FORWARD.
AB.
YOU'RE RIGHT CALIFORNIA'S
ENFORCEABLE IN ESPECIALLY
VETERANS ON A FIXED INCOME OR
ANY.
PERSON BUT ANYBODY WHO'S WILLING
TO PICK UP A WEAPON AND IF IN
THIS COUNTRY.
AND WE SHOULD REMEMBER THEM AND
TAKE CARE OF THEM BECAUSE WE
WOULDN'T BE SITTING HERE TODAY
WITHOUT ALL OF YOU.
SO I CENTER SHOWN THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES THIS IS SO IMPORTANT
TO OPEN THE DOOR AND MAYBE EVEN
KEEP THE DOOR. FOR OUR VETERANS
AND ALL OF YOU HAVE SURE OF YOU
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT SHOULD
SAID THAT WILL BE THE FIRST STEP --
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
RECOGNIZE ALL OF YOUR SERVICE SO
WITH THAT -- TO THE ROPE PLACE.
SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY FOUR TO
PASS BUT IS REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS ARCHULETA. 100%
YES ACTUALLY I GROW.
GROVE HI HER TADO.
NIELSEN NIELSEN HI ROTH.
ROTH AYE NUMBER.
WILK.
WILK HI.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA HOLD OVER THE
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH I GOT A
LITTLE EXCITED THERE MYSELF.
THANK YOU MANY DAYS [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SO -- WHO IS HERE?
MORRELL.
OKAY SAID WELL WE'RE GONNA TAKE
YOU NEXT [inaudible]
SAID OKAY.
THAT WAS ABOUT [inaudible]
TWENTY THANK.
THANK YOU -- SENATOR MORALE
YEARS YES -- SB FIVE SIX TO GO
IN YOUR BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON -- FIVE SIXTY TWO WILL
INCREASE THE CURRENT -- PROPERTY
TAX EXEMPTIONS FOR DISABLED VETS.
MANNER.
UNMARRIED -- SURVIVING SPOUSES.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS TO
ENSURE THE EXEMPTIONS WE PROVIDETO THE VETERANS TO KEEP UP WITH
THE COST OF HOUSING.
AND LIVING IN A VERY EXPENSIVE
CALIFORNIA. FOR VETERAN LIVING
ONLY ON DISABILITY PENSION CAN
BE DIFFICULT TO AFFORD THE
RISING.
COST OF HOUSING SO CURRENTLY --
MONTHLY TAKE HOME FOR QUALIFYING --
DISABLED VETS WITH THE PENANCES
APPROXIMATE THIRTY THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS.
ACCORDING TO THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE I THINK WE ALL KNOW
THE MEDIAN HOME VALUE IN
CALIFORNIA'S -- ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY SIX THOUSAND OR
ABOUT TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER MONTH.
AT MINIMUM THE PROPERTY TAX FOR
HOME.
OF THAT COST WILL STILL EXCEED
FIVE THOUSAND PER YEAR SO
THERE'S CLEARLY A BIG GAP
BETWEEN THE TAKE HOME PAY AND
THE COST OF A HOME AT IN -- AT
THE CURRENT HOUSING PRICES A
TAXES ALONG.
CANADA'S AS WE KNOW CAN BE
OVERWHELMING SO WITH THIS BILL A
DISABLED VETERAN WITH THE
TENANTS AND NO OTHER INCOME
WOULD BE ENTITLED TO THE LOW
INCOME EXEMPTION.
WOULD YOU BE REYES FROM TWO
HUNDRED AND 200-022-0050
THOUSAND A VETERAN WITH A
HOUSEHOLD INCOME OVER SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND FOR YOUR WOULD SEE AN
INCREASE FROM.
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND
TO TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND SB FIVE
SIXTY TO KEEP THE EXISTING
EXEMPTIONS ON BASE WITH HOUSING
COSTS.
AND THE BILL PASSES -- SEVEN
SENATE FINANCE COMMITTEE WITH.
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT SIX ZERO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IS THERE ANYONE -- IN ATTENDANCE
TO SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE
COME FORWARD AND THE MICROPHONE.
ELEVEN MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
GREG HAYES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
YEAH.
IN GOTHAM CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL VIETNAM VETERANS OF
AMERICA WE SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
THANK YOU SEN TOMORROW
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IN A SAFE VETERANS BUSINESS
ALLIANCE IN WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MANY MONTONEROS THE UNITED
STATES BUSINESS LINES WE
SUPPORTED WHOLE HEARTEDLY.
JACK SMITH WITH US BETTER
BUSINESS PLANS [inaudible]
FOR THANK YOU. THREE IN PLUS I'M
ON THIS LIST OF AND THAT TIME
THE THIRD VICE COMMANDER THE
STATE ORGANIZATION AND NATIONAL
VICE CHAIR WE SHOULD COME UP
WHAT. FOUR ONE WITH A BILL LIKE
THIS FIRST SINGLE GRAMOS OF FIVE
BUT WE'RE IN SUPPORT ANYWAY.
THANK YOU.
I SEE NO OTHERS -- ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
WHERE MOST [inaudible]
THE BILL.
MOVE TO MOVE THE BILL THE
QUESTION THE COMMENT.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATE BILL FIVE SIXTY TWO DO
PATH BUT FIRST RE REFER TO
PREPARATIONS ARCHULETA.
I EXCELLENT I GREW.
GROUP I HER DAUGHTER.
NIELSEN NIELSEN I ROTH.
I AM VERY.
WILK.
GENERAL OPEN WOULD HOLD IT OPEN
THANK YOU SIR [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH
[inaudible]
I'M HERE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YOU'RE
GOING TO PRESENT SB [inaudible]
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT YES -- THANK
YOU A MEDICARE.
THE GERMAN HONORED TO PRESENT --
SENATE VETERANS BILL -- SB.
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT A LITTLE BIT.
SENATE BILL.
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT AND THIS IS --
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR CONSIDERING THE SENATE BILL
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH PERTAINS
TO THE DISABLED VETERANS
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE.
THIS DISABLED VETERANS BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE AND THAT PROGRAM.
EXISTING LAW MANDATES THAT
AWARDING APARTMENTS UPON%
COMPLETION OF EVERY D. V. BE
CONTRACT WILL BE RICK -- WILL
REQUIRE THE PRIME CONTRACTOR
CERTIFY INFORMATION RELATED TO
ANY -- VETERAN -- CUT THE
SUBCONTRACTORS PARTICIPATING IN
THE PERFORMANCE OF THE CONTRACT
TO INCLUDE.
A TOTAL AMOUNT OF PRIME
CONTRACTOR RECEIVED UNDER THE
CONTRACT.
AND WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT
OFTENTIMES.
THE MAJOR CONTRACTOR.
WE'LL FIND A SUBCONTRACTOR WHO
HAS VETERANS WITHIN THEIR RANKS
AND USE THAT VETERAN.
AS THE AS THE LOOP I WILL WE'LL
CALL IT THE THE SUPPORTING
FACTOR WHEN IN REALITY.
THAT BETTER AND HAS NO KNOWLEDGE
THAT HIS NAME WAS BEING USED AND
HIS SERVICE.
CHAU ONE BEING THE SUBCONTRACTOR
IN THE OTHER.
SHOW THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF PRIME
CONTRACTOR RECEIVED UNDER THE
CONTRACT.
MUST BE DISCLOSED THE AMOUNT
EACH OF DEPARTMENT OF WERE --
EACH SUBCONTRACTOR RECEIVED FROM
THE PRIME CONTRACTOR AND THAT
ALL PAYMENTS OLD UNDER THE
CONTRACT HAVE BEEN MADE AND PICK
MADE PAYABLE TO THE D. B. B. E..
THESE SUBCONTRACT PAYMENTS
RECORDS ARE IMPORTANT IN
MEASURING THE PROGRAM GOAL.
ATTAINED.
POTENTIAL OF PROGRAMS WASTE AND
FRAUD IN THAT IS THE PRIMARY
ISSUE.
THE WASTE IN THE FRAUD
FURTHERMORE EXISTING LAW IMPOSES
SEVERE FINANCIAL PENALTIES AND
CIVIL LIABILITIES.
ON ANYONE WHO KNOWINGLY PROVIDE
FALSE INFORMATION IN MAKING THE
CERTIFICATION.
THE VETERANS MUST NOT BE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
AND TWENTY NINETEEN FALLING OUT
ITS OF THE D. B. B. E. PROGRAM
THE STATE ATER REPORTED THAT
MANY.
CONTRACT AWARDED DEPARTMENTS.
ARE DOING A WRETCHED JOB IN
ACQUIRING AND MAINTAINING
CERTIFICATIONS.
OF THESE APPROVED -- BETTER AND
SUBCONTRACTORS AND THE PAYMENTS
MADE TO THEM.
SO.
WHEN A VETERAN IS IS UTILIZED HE
THE SUBCONTRACTORS TO RECEIVE
HIS PAYMENTS?
OF FOR THE WORK DONE AND HIS
INVOLVEMENT IN OFTENTIMES.
PAYMENTS ARE NEVER MADE.
IN ITS FALSIFICATIONS AND FALL
CERTIFICATION.
WHILE EXISTING LAW PROHIBITS I'M
SORRY WE'RE EXISTING LAW
PROVIDES SERIOUS PENALTIES FOR
PRIME CONTRACTORS WHO KNOWINGLY
PROVIDE FALSE INFORMATION. TO AN
AWARDING DEPARTMENT REGARDING AS
PAYMENTS TO SUBCONTRACTED THERE
IS NO CORRESPONDING PENALTY FOR
PRIME CONTRACTORS SIMPLY FAILING
TO PROVIDE THE INFORMATION AT
ALL.
AND THIS WILL OPEN THAT DOOR TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT -- MAIN
PRIME CONTRACTOR AND HIS
INFORMATION IS IS CERTIFIED AND
IT IS TRUE.
THE THE LACK OF ENFORCEMENT TOOL.
FOR CONTRIBUTED TO THIS DATA IS --
IS THE AWARDING OF SO MANY
CONTRACTS WHICH OBVIOUSLY
BELIEVES THAT.
THAT SUBCONTRACT OUT
SUBCONTRACTOR OUT OF THE
EQUATION.
SUBCONTRACTORS HAVE INFORMED.
I AND MY STAFF THAT THEY ARE
BEING -- UNDER USED AND AND
UNDER PAID AND IN SOME CASES
THEY ARE EVEN IT LISTED.
ON THE D. B. B. E. BIDS.
BY PRIME CONTRACTORS WITHOUT
EVEN BEING INFORMED AS I HAD
MENTIONED OR BEING NOTIFIED SO
THESE VETERANS ARE ACTUALLY
BEING USED IN TAKING TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF SB FIVE EIGHTY
EIGHT CREATION ENFORCEMENT DOORS
FOLLOWED.
WHEN A PRIME CONTRACTOR FAILED
TO REPORT US UP REPORTS
SUBCONTRACTOR PAYMENTS?
THE AWARDING DEPARTMENT WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO NOTIFY THE
CONTRACTOR FROM AND GIVE IT A
REASONABLE TIME TO REPORT THE
DATA.
AND FOR A CONTRACTOR THAT FAILED
TO RESPOND -- TO PROMPTING --
WITHIN A REASONABLE TIME.
THE FIRST TIME PENALTY IS A FIVE
YEAR SUSPENSION FOR
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAM
RELATED TO CONTRACTS FOR
VETERANS.
A SECOND VIOLATION EARNED
PERMANENT SUSPENSION.
THE SUSPENSION FROM ALLSTATE
RELATED CONTRACTS.
CONTRACT PERTAINING TO THE STATE
A VERY LUCRATIVE AND IT SHOULD
BE WITH VETERANS IN MIND.
IT NOT BEING TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF
OUR FIRST ASSUMPTION IS THAT ALL
PRIME CONTRACTORS EVERYWHERE
MAINTAIN RECORDS OF THEIR
PAYMENTS TO SUBCONTRACTORS.
JUST FOR THE GENERAL BUSINESS
MANAGER AND TAX PURPOSES.
THEY HAVE THE DATA AND MUST BE A
TRANSPARENT.
OUR SECOND ASSUMPTION.
PORT PAYMENT MAYBE DUE TO SIMPLE
FORGETFULNESS OR BENIGN AIR.
BUT FAILURE TO REPORT.
THESE -- PAYMENTS OR LACK OF
PAYMENT SHOULD BEING REMINDED
AND GIVEN REASONABLE TIME TO
INDICATE WILLFUL INTENT TO AVOID
DISCLOSING DATA.
WHICH WOULD HURT THE VETERANS.
DATA THAT MIGHT INDICATE THAT
CONTRACTORS UNDER AS AS BEING
UNDER PAID OR NOT PAID AT ALL
AND SOME CAGES AND THE
SUBCONTRACTOR IS BEING USED --
AND WE MUST STOP THAT TYPE OF OF
ACTION MUST PLUG THE DATA LIEU
POSTED SO WE CAN ANALYZE THE
PROGRAM PROPERLY -- WITH ME
TODAY I HAVE DRAKE MATT AND MANY
MARTINEZ TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT A
RETREAT EIFFEL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GENTLEMEN
WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY WE HAVE FIVE
MINUTES BETWEEN ALL OF YOU THIS
OF TEARS RULES.
I'LL START OFF THE DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESS PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED IN. NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE TWO GLARING MISTAKES IN.
OUR THINGS LEFT OUT OF THE BILL
AT THAT TIME.
ONE WAS WHAT WE CALLED THE GOOD
FAITH EFFORT WHERE THE
CONTRACTOR COULD GO OUT AND SHOP
THREE DIFFERENT -- VENUES AND IF
YOU DIDN'T GET A DISABLED THAT
THAT HE DIDN'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT.
THE ONE THAT -- SENATOR
ARCHULETA BROUGHT UP IS THE ONE
THAT IS BEEN THE MOST TROUBLING.
I CAN GIVE YOU A PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE IT'S GOING ON RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE A CONTRACT WITH
PARSONS.
TRANSPORTATION.
IT'S A THREE HUNDRED ELEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLAR CONTRACT.
IS AND IT'S A CALTRANS LA METRO
JOINT POLICY OR JOINT BID.
AND THEY HAVE SAID THAT THEY
WOULD BE USING US AND THEY HAVE
NEVER USED TO US WE HAVE A
SIGNED CONTRACT FROM THEM THERE
IS NO PUNISHMENT FOR THEM FOR
NOT USING US.
THEY ARE GUEST SHINING US ON AND
THAT'S THE ROBLEM THAT WE HAVE
WITH THIS.
SITUATION THAT'S GOING ON RIGHT
WE NEED TO PUT TEETH INTO IT
THIS WILL PUT TEETH IN.
WE NEED THAT TO PROTECT THE
VETERANS PROTECT THE VETERAN
BUSINESS ENTERPRISES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ANOTHER THING THAT CAME OUT THE
AUDIT SHOWED THAT THERE WAS ONLY
A SMALL PERCENTAGE OF THE
VETERAN ARE DISABLED VETERAN
OWNED BUSINESSES.
THAT WE'RE GETTING MOST OF THE
WORK IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE AUDIT IS AN ACCURATE BECAUSE
IT DOES NOT LOOK AT
SUBCONTRACTING WE DO
SUBCONTRACTING EXCLUSIVELY WE
ARE NOT A PRIME CONTRACTOR.
IF THAT INFORMATION WAS PUT INTO
THAT AUDIT IT WOULD SHOW THAT
THIS PROGRAM IS DOING FANTASTIC.
WHAT WE NEED IS THE T. IN THIS
BILL TO GET IT THROUGH TO
ENFORCE THOSE PRIME CONTRACTORS
TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT?
IN THE CONSTRUCTION SIDE THEY
HAVE REGULATIONS THAT ENFORCE
THAT BUT NOT FOR THE DISABLED
VETERANS SO WE NEED TO HAVE THAT
DONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
[inaudible]
AND ALL OF YOU.
THANK YOU DRAKE -- I ALSO HAVE
BEEN.
A VICTIM OF THIS -- THIS ABUSE.
STAFF SERGEANT MANY MOUNTAIN IS
RETIRED US ARMY I HEAR THAT A
MINUTE AGO I WAS WOUNDED IN
VIETNAM -- THIS IS A COPY OF MY
LAKE THERE ALL.
BUT ANYWAY I'M I'M GOING TO
SHARE THIS ONLY BECAUSE TED
POINT TESTS WHO IS I'M SPEAKING
ON HIS BEHALF BUT I'M ALSO.
CONSIDER HIS BROTHER FROM
ANOTHER MOTHER BOTH VERY
DISABLED VETS.
IN SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
UNITED STATES THE VETERAN
BUSINESS LINES LEGISLATIVE AND
POLICY DEVELOPMENT CHAIR TED
POINT HAS WHO WASN'T ABLE TO
MAKE THE TRIP. TO GIVE A WITNESS
TESTIMONY.
I MENTIONED EARLIER I HAD SERVED
ON THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL OF ORANGE
COUNTY.
AND I ENSURING THE CHALK WALK
TWO YEARS IN A ROW I GET CALLS
FROM FRIENDS.
THEY SAY MANY MY CHILD IS.
ILLNESS AND WE'RE TAKE THEM TO
CHALK CAN YOU HELP US OUT I GO
OUT OF MY WAY I'VE DONE IT
PROBABLY FOUR TIMES I JUST
RECEIVED THIS CALL FROM TED
POINT TO SO.
HIS SON WAS DIAGNOSED WITH A
RARE FORM OF BLOOD CANCER.
UNTREATABLE BUT THEY CAN MONITOR
BUT SO I'M READING HIS HEARTFELT
SENTIMENTS AT THIS MOMENT SO
BEAR WITH ME.
SO REMEMBER HE ENJOYED MEETING
YOU RECENTLY.
TED I AM A TEN YEAR DV B. E. MY
BUSINESS IS FOCUSED ON IT
CONSULTING STAFFING BUSINESS
PROCESS AND BACK OFFICE SUPPORT.
APPROXIMATELY THREE YEARS AFTER
A LAUNCH MY BUSINESS I WAS
APPROACHED BY NEEDS COAST PRIME
CONTRACTOR.
AFTER BEING THERE STEVIE B. E.
SUBCONTRACTOR ON A THIRTY
MILLION DOLLAR PROJECT WITH
CALPERS.
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL WEEKS I
ENGAGED IN SEVERAL CONVERSATIONS
REGARDING THE OPPORTUNITY THE
SCOPE OF SERVICES MY COMPANY
WOULD PERFORM.
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS I
LEFT VOICE MAILS NO RESPONSE.
APPROXIMATELY FIVE YEARS LATER I
MAKING THE SHORT TO CONFORM WITH
THE TIME APPROXIMATELY FIVE
YEARS LATER I RECEIVED A CALL
FROM THE SMALL BUSINESS AND DVB
ADVOCATE FOR CALPERS.
ENQUIRING IF I PERFORMED ON A
CONTRACT WITH THEM A THE DVB
AECON SUBCONTRACTOR.
I ASKED TOWARD CONTRACT SHE
BEGAN EXPLAINING THE BASIS OF
THE CONTRACT AND THEY SHARED
WITH HER I THOUGHT THE COMPANY
LOST THE BID BECAUSE I COULDN'T
GET ANYONE ON THE PHONE.
OR REPLY TO MY EMAILS.
I ASKED THE ADVOCATE WHAT'S THE
PUNISHMENT FOR THIS KIND OF
FRAUD AND SHE REPLIED THERE IS
NONE.
BECAUSE OF THE FRAUD CONDUCTED
BY THIS PRIME MY FIRM LOST
SEVERAL. THOUSAND DOLLARS WORTH
OF BUSINESS AND A LOT OF TIME
EFFORT AND RESOURCES SPENT
SUPPORTING THEIR BED.
SB FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT ELIMINATES
AS PRIME CONTRACTOR FRAUD ONCE
AND FOR ALL AND HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE AND FINALLY PUNISHES
THEM FOR CONDUCTING FRAUD.
SB FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT IS THIRTY
YEARS OVERDUE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TED POINT [inaudible]
IN A JACK SMITH I'M ON THE U. S.
VETERAN BUSINESS ALLIANCE AND CO
FOURTEEN TO BE MC A LAST YEAR WE
WERE THE SECOND FASTEST GROWING
COMPANY IN SACRAMENTO.
THIS PROGRAM IS DIRECTLY RELATED
TO THAT AND IS THAT
SUBCONTRACTOR MODEL THAT ALLOWS
US TO BE ABLE TO COMPETE ON
THESE HIGH LEVELS.
THIS PROGRAM MAKES THOSE PRIME
CONTRACTORS BE ABLE TO DO ALL
THE THINGS THAT TED WAS TALKING
ABOUT IT AND THE USE US ALL THE
TIME.
WITHOUT TELLING US AND WE
THERE'S NO WAY FOR US TO KNOW
YOU KNOW WHETHER THE BILL AS ARE
THE WEATHER THAT'S BEEN AWARDED
OR NOT TO TO TOUCH POINT -- SO
THIS OVERSIGHT WE'LL GIVE YOU
THAT VISIBILITY AND WE'LL SHOW
YOU HOW THIS PROGRAM IS DRIVING
BUSINESS IT'S KEEPING MONEY HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
HIRING CALIFORNIA.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SET THREE
THREE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
REPRESENTING AMERICAN GI FORM.
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION COUNTY
VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDERS
VETERANS COUNCIL.
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF CHAPTERS
NATIONAL GUARD SPECIATION.
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS GARY ROSS I'M
REPRESENTING AMERICAN LEGION
DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA AND WE
SUPPORT THIS BLL THANK YOU SIR.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION ARE MORE
SUPPORT SORRY EMBED SUPPORT
DURING CLASS THANK YOU WEARING.
ANYONE AND ALSO SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SEEN ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED.
SENATOR CHIRLA THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AT PRIME CONTRACTORS DO
GET A DISCOUNT AS OF WAGE OR A
BIG PREFERENTIAL.
USING THE TV B. E. OR W. A. B.
E. BUT IN THIS CASE DVB.
AND THEY GET TO BID A HIGHER
DOLLAR AMOUNT TO AND THEY GET
CONSIDERATION FOR NOT HAVING THE
LOWEST BID WHEN THEY BUT SOMEONE
LIKE A MILITARY VETERAN ON THAT
SO I APPRECIATE THIS
ACCOUNTABILITY BILL BECAUSE
VETERANS SHOULD NOT BE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF SO QUICKLY CULTURAL.
SENATE BILL FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT TO
PASS BUT FIRST RE APPROPRIATIONS
ARCHULETA I ARCHULETA I GROW BY
GROUP I HER DAUGHTER.
NIELSEN.
ROTH.
ROTH AYE NUMBER.
NUMBER I WILL. FOR THE FIFTH AT
ONE HOTEL ROOMS.
THE REAL OPEN SIR THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND I KNOW THE
DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE A VERY HAPPY TO NOTE.
THAT WE HAVE SUPPORTED THIS BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU
[inaudible]
YOUR UP.
CENTER JONES YOU HAVE SB.
SIX SIX THREE I DO PLEASE
PRESENT YOUR BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU
CHAIR -- FIRST OF ALL I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR -- FOR
BEING A CO AUTHOR I APPRECIATE
THAT.
SENATE BILL SIX SIXTY THREE
PROVIDES A PROPERTY TAX
EXEMPTION FOR PROPERTY OWNED BY
A VETERAN ORGANIZATION.
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS A WELFARE
EXEMPTION FOR PROPERTY TAXES FOR
NON PROFITS IS JUST RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS HOSPITALS AND
VETERAN ORGANIZATIONS.
HOWEVER THIS EXEMPTION ONLY
APPLIES TO PORTIONS OF THE
PROPERTY USED EXCLUSIVELY FOR
CHARITABLE PURPOSES.
SUCH AS ROOMS USED FOR
COUNSELING SERVICES.
THIS BILL WILL EXTEND THE
PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION TO ALL
PARTS OF THE PROPERTY EXCEPT --
BAR.
SB SIX SIXTY THREE WILL PROVIDE
SUPPORT TO VETERANS HALLS THAT
ARE TRYING TO ENHANCE THE SOCIAL
WELFARE.
OF CURRENT AND FORMER MILITARY
PERSONNEL.
THIS BILL IS IDENTICAL TO
ASSEMBLY MEN.
GRAZE BILL FROM LAST SESSION
WHOM I'M ALSO PROUD TO HAVE AS A
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR.
THE BILL PASSED UNANIMOUSLY IN
BOTH HOUSES BUT WAS VETOED BY
THE GOVERNOR I AM I GOVERNOR
BROWN AT THE TIME.
I WITH ME TODAY IS SET THREE BUT
ON BEHALF [inaudible]
CAN LEGION.
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS I'M SET
THREE WITH THREE GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS FOR VET REPRESENTING
AMERICAN JEFF FORM.
OF CALIFORNIA AMERICAN LEGION
DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA WHO IS
SPONSORED.
AND THAT'S DEPARTMENT OF
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION COUNTY VETERANS
SERVICE OFFICERS CALIFORNIA
STATE COMMANDERS VETERANS
COUNCIL NATIONAL GUARD
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA AND THE
VIETNAM VETERANS OF AMERICA.
ALL IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX SIX
THREE I SERVED IN THE ARMY FROM
200-042-2000 NINE AS AN
INFANTRYMAN I DEPLOYED TO BOTH
IRAQ AND AFGHANISTAN.
SB SIX SIX THREE WILL HELP
NONPROFIT VETERANS SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS INCREASE THEIR
MORALE WELFARE PROGRAMS.
VETERAN ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDE
IMPORTANT SERVICES TO VETERANS
SUCH AS PEER TO PEER SUPPORT
COUNSELING.
ASSISTANCE WITH APPLYING FOR
BENEFITS AND VETERAN OUTREACH
MANY VETERAN HOLES OPERATE ON A
SMALL BUDGET MADE UP LARGELY OF
DONATIONS AND THE VETERANS
MEMBERSHIP DUES. FOR EXAMPLE MY
POST HAS A SMALL BUDGET FOR
SUPPORTING VETERANS.
IN THE COMMUNITY IF F. F. SB SIX
SIX THREE IS SIGNED INTO LAW.
IT WOULD SAVE MY POST
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR AND THOSE FUNDS
COULD BE SHIFTED TO BETTER
SUPPORT VETERANS IN THE
COMMUNITY.
VETERANS HALLS ALSO SERVE A
PUBLIC AND CIVIC FUNCTION
COMMUNITY.
COMMUNITY MEETINGS BOY SCOUT
FUNCTIONS.
AND A HOST OF OTHER COMMUNITY
GROUPS UTILIZING THE VETERAN
HALL.
THE CALIFORNIA SAYS HIS
ASSOCIATION IS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION AND HAS STATED.
THERE THAT CLASS CLARIFICATION
OF SUCH AN EXEMPTION MAKES THE
PROCESS MORE EFFICIENT AND SB
SIX SIX THREE WILL SIMPLIFY.
THE PROCESS FOR SAYS.
ANYONE IN THE AUDIENCE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
SETH ALREADY MENTIONED IT BUT TO
OF THE VIETNAM VETERANS OF
AMERICA FOR STATE COUNCIL
SUPPORTS THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
BRING US TO PARTICIPATE THANK
YOU MA'AM.
AMERICAN LEGION DEPARTED CAL.
UNITED STATES VETERANS BUSINESS
ALLIANCE WILL PARTS BILL THANK
YOU SIR.
FREE FUTURES PROJECT FIVE OH ONE
C. THREE SUPPORTS THIS BILL
THANK YOU SIR.
IT'S YOUR ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION.
NONE.
OKAY MEMBERS.
THE BILL WELL IT WAS CHAIR I'M
HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL AS ONE
MAKE SURE THAT I'M CLEAR THE THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS THAT WE WERE.
HANDED SIMPLY ADD COHEN RIGHT.
RIGHT.
AND HAVE THESE ARE AS A BILL
ALREADY BEEN AMENDED OR IS IT
GOING TO THESE MEN IN THE BILL
IN COMMITTEE.
OKAY -- MOVE THE BILL -- WITH
THESE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENT YES HELLO THIS
CALL OF THE ROLL.
SENATE BILL SIX SIX THREE TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
THROUGH REFERRED PREPARATIONS
ARCHULETA.
I I GREW GROUP I BOTTOM.
NIELSEN.
ROTH HI ROTH AYE NUMBER.
NUMBER I WILK [inaudible] FOR
GONNA HOLD IT OVER A CLOSING
COMMENT.
WELL I'VE GOT THE VOTES OF THANK
YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
REGULATIONS [inaudible] THREE
EVEN [inaudible]
WHAT'S THE SENATOR UMBERG YOU'D
HAVE -- BILL SB.
FOUR EIGHTY ONE AHEAD PRESENT
YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU -- THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
COURSE SOME HOUSEKEEPING
MEASURES.
THERE WERE SOME PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS THAT WE WORKED WITH
THE STAFF BY THE WAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YOUR STAFF CHIEF
CONSULTANT HAS BEEN QUITE.
HELPFUL IN SPENT QUITE A BIT OF
TIME WORKING OUT.
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS -- ONE
EXCEPTION TO THAT IS THE
AMENDMENT.
THAT IS CONTAINED AT IN SECTION.
THREE FIFTY SIX ONE HE IS AN
BROUGH.
OF THAT AMENDMENT WHAT WHAT ARE
YOU ARE YOU ON PAGE UP UNDER THE
PROPOSED SUBSTANTIVE AMENDMENTS
IF YOU LOOK AT PAGE -- ALL RIGHT
OFF OF IT SAYS PAGE.
ELEVEN YOU SEE THAT AND THEN
THERE'S A PARAGRAPH.
SOME DE.
ON PAGE ELEVEN OF THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS [inaudible]
SURE.
PAGE.
FIVE SOCIAL RULES [inaudible]
SECTION.
THREE MORE ON THE YEAH.
YEAH BUT WHAT ABOUT.
OKAY.
SO -- WE WE ACCEPT ALL THOSE
AMENDMENTS ALL THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS -- THE ONE ISSUE THAT
REALLY IS BEFORE US IS WITH
RESPECT TO WHAT'S KNOWN AS A
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION.
PURPOSES BILLS TO FULL FIRST
FIRST PURPOSE IS TO ENSURE THAT
FOR EXAMPLE ALLEGATIONS
CONCERNING -- SENIOR MILITARY
OFFICIALS WITHIN THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT.
GO TO THE GOVERNOR ULTIMATELY TO
THE GOVERNOR WHO IS COMMANDER IN
CHIEF OF THE OF THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL GUARD AND STATE
MILITARY DEPARTMENT.
THAT'S ONE ISSUE I THINK THAT
ISSUE HAS BEEN.
AT LEAST IN TERMS OF CONTROVERSY
IT HAS BEEN RESOLVED THE SECOND
THOUGH IS AN ISSUE CONCERNING
EQUALITY.
IT'S EQUALITY WITH RESPECT -- TO
IT MEANT OF SERVICE MEMBERS.
IN THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN ACCUSED
OF HARMING SERVICE MEMBERS AND
HOW THEY'RE TREATED.
SO.
JUST TO ILLUSTRATE THE POINT.
IF YOU HAVE TO INDIVIDUALS ONE
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS IN UNIFORM WHO
IS ON STATE ACTIVE DUTY.
AND THAT INDIVIDUAL -- FOR
EXAMPLE HARASSES ANOTHER
INDIVIDUAL.
SERVICE MEMBER.
THAT INDIVIDUAL CURRENTLY IS
PROTECTED BY WHAT'S KNOWN AS THE
FAIRS STOCKTON WHICH IN EFFECT
PROVIDES IMMUNITY. TO THE PERSON
WHO IS ACCUSED OF HARASSING THE
OTHER SERVICE MEMBERS.
NOW JUXTAPOZ THAT TO SOMEONE WHO
IS SITTING RIGHT NEXT TO HIM OR
HER.
RIGHT NEXT TO THE ACCUSER WHO IS
ENGAGED IN THE EXACT SAME
CONDUCT BUT AS A CIVILIAN.
IF THAT PERSON IS A CIVILIAN
ENGAGES IN THE EXACT SAME
CONDUCT.
THEN THE VICTIM OR THE PURPORTED
VICTIM OF THAT HARASSMENT.
AS AN ABILITY TO SEEK CIVIL
REDRESS.
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS THIS
BILL DOES IN THE CONSEQUENCE IN
THE CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE YOU HAVE
A WHISTLE BLOWER.
WHERE THE WHISTLE BLOWER HAS
MADE AN ALLEGATION THE BILL
PROVIDES GOOD FAITH ALLEGATION?
MAKES AN ALLEGATION AGAINST
ANOTHER SERVICE MEMBER. TO THE
EXTENT THAT THAT THEY ARE
RETALIATED GETS TO THE EXTENT
THAT THEY ARE HARMED.
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO SEEK
CIVIL REDRESS JUST LIKE IF THE
PERSON WHO WAS ACCUSED OF THAT
HARM.
WERE CIVILIAN -- THE PROTECTIONS
PROVIDED BY THE FAIRS DOCTOR AND
WHICH IS A A DOCTRINE THAT THE
OF ALL FROM A CASE OF THE UNITED
STATES FERS FERRIS.
IN.
NINETEEN FIFTY HAS BEEN REBUKED
NEARLY UNIVERSALLY.
EVEN.
JUSTICE ANTONIN SCALIA.
WHEN REFERRING TO AFFAIRS DR
THAT'S THE DOCTOR AGAIN THAT
THAT PROTECTS AND IMMUNIZE IS IN
ESSENCE MILITARY MEMBERS?
SAID THE FOLLOWING SAID FAIRS
VERSUS UNITED STATES WAS WRONGLY
DECIDED AND HARDLY DESERVES THE
WIDESPREAD AND ALMOST UNIVERSAL
CRITICISM IT IS RUN RISK IT IS
RECEIVED.
THIS ISSUE CONCERNING THE FAIRS
DOCTRINE IS RIGHT NOW.
BEING CONSIDERED FOR REVIEW BY
THE UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
WE ANTICIPATE THAT ANY DAY ANY
DAY THE SUPREME COURT WILL
DECIDE WHETHER GOING TO TAKE UP
THIS ISSUE -- IF.
IT'S BEEN SAID IN THE PAST IS
PROLOGUE.
BY A NUMBER OF COMMENTATORS BOTH
CONSERVATIVE AND THOSE WERE NOT
CONSERVATIVE.
THEN I I EXPECTED THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT WILL TAKE
UP.
IN RESPECT OF A WHERE THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT TAKES UP
THIS.
WHAT I BELIEVED TO BE -- THIS
IMPROPER.
IMMUNIZATION OF MILITARY MEMBERS
WHO HAVE ENGAGED IN MISCONDUCT
IRRESPECTIVE OF WHETHER TAKE IT
UP WITH THIS BILL THIS
PARTICULAR PROVISION THIS. ONE
AMENDMENT THIS ONE PROVISION OF
THIS AMENDMENT THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
THEN.
WOULD ESTABLISH A CALIFORNIA
BASICALLY ONCE AGAIN IS IN THE
FOREFRONT OF PRINT PROVIDING
PROTECTIONS FOR THOSE WHO ARE
WHISTLE BLOWERS.
HAVING SAID THAT I HAVE NUMBER
OF EXPERTS I'M MERELY HERE IS
THE AUTHOR OF NUMBER OF EXPERTS
HERE. TO TESTIFY -- WITH RESPECT
TO THE IMPACTS OF THE BILL IN
PARTICULAR CONCERNING THE THE
MOMENT THAT IS AT ISSUE OR THE
PORTION MOMENT THAT THAT'S AT
ISSUE.
THAT DATA FIRES.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TOM BARTH AND I AM --
COUNCIL WORKING WITH THE
NATIONAL GUARD ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA -- MY BACKGROUND
BRIEFLY IS -- WEST POINT GRAD OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE I SERVE
TWELVE YEARS ACTIVE DUTY AND
THEN RETIRED FROM CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL GUARD.
MOST OF MY TIME ACTIVE DUTY AND
GUARD WAS AS A JAG ATTORNEY.
AND SO I'VE FIVE DELTA --
FRANKLY ON THE MILITARY IN THE
MILITARY CONTEXT TO A LIMITED
EXTENT BUT DEFINITELY IN MY POST.
RETIREMENT CIVILIAN PRACTICE --
WITH -- WITH VARIOUS ASPECTS OF
THIS VARIES DOCTOR AND HOW IT'S
HOW IT-- MANIFESTS SO
ADDRESSING THIS PARTICULAR WHAT
WHAT APPEARS TO BE.
YOU KNOW THE FOCUS OF OF THE
DISCUSSION OF FIFTY SIX POINT
ONE A SUBDIVISION BE -- YEAH
THIS THIS ISN'T ACTUALLY NEW --
FOR A STATE TO ALLOW -- A CIVIL --
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION -- THE
OTHER STATES -- OF NOTABLY
ALASKA AND STATE WASHINGTON -- I
HAVE GONE THIS ROUTE IN VARYING
DEGREES I THINK WHAT'S KEY. TO
ADDRESS THE UNDERSTANDABLE
CONCERNS -- WITH RESPECT TO
MILITARY GOOD ORDER AND
DISCIPLINE IN THE FUNCTION AND
OPERATION.
OF THE MILITARY IS TO HAVE A
VERY WELL DEFINED -- IN SPLIT
AND SPECIFIC -- STANDARD -- BY
WHICH A PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
MAY BE INVOKED SO -- ARE.
UNDERSTANDABLY IT SHOULD NOT BE --
FRANKLY AS IN ALASKA WHERE THEY
CAN SUE FOR ANY MANNER OF
NEGLIGENCE -- THIS ONE IS VERY
SPECIFICALLY TAILORED IN ORDER
TO ADDRESS AND IT CONCERNS THAT
MAY BE QUITE UNDERSTANDABLE
ABOUT -- DISRUPTION OF THE
MILITARY -- PROCESS SO IT'S IT'S
IT IS THOUGH RELATIVELY NEW AND
NOVEL APPROACH BUT IT IS
FUNDAMENTALLY -- AT THE ROCKET
IF OF THE LEGISLATURE IN YOUR
HANDS IN THE FIRST INSTANCE TO
DECIDE.
WHETHER AND TO WHAT EXTENT --
THIS -- PROTECTION OR OR OR
SHROUD IF YOU WILL AGAINST ANY
ACCOUNTABILITY OF MILITARY
ACTORS -- IS LIFTED TO A TO A
DEGREE -- SO WE GET THE IF THERE
ANY QUESTIONS LIKE ADDRESS.
THE OTHER REST.
OF EXPERT WITNESSES [inaudible]
CENTER.
SURE MR MAS.
THANK YOU SENATOR JOHN HER
MOLLIS ALLEGEDLY DIRECT FOR THE
NATIONAL GUARD ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA SPENT. THREE DECADES
IN THE DEPARTMENT -- WEHAVE
WITNESSED A SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER.
COMPLAIN SAID WE HAVE BEEN
PROVIDING ASSISTANCE WITH OUR
OFFICE IN THE LAST. SIX OR SEVEN
YEARS PRIMARILY AND HAVE BEEN
HELPING FOR THOSE ON TO THE
PROPER AUTHORITIES FOR A FINAL
INVESTIGATION WHAT WE FIND
THOUGH IS THAT.
WE'RE A AS WE HELP MOVE SOME OF
THESE THROUGH AND AND SEE THE
CONCLUSION THAT IS.
REACH WE FIND THAT THE WHISTLE
BLOWERS ARE NOT REALLY PROTECTED
ALL THIS PARTICULAR SYSTEM.
THERE ARE WAYS TO ADVANCE A
COMPLAINT IN THE STATE SYSTEM
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY
THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT THAT
ANYBODY TAKE ANY ACTION ON IT
AND THAT CAN BE A SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEM.
SOMETIMES THE FEDERAL SYSTEM.
PLEASE TAKE A LONG TIME TO
INVESTIGATE AND THEY SIMPLY.
GET FILED AWAY PEOPLE RETIRED
PEOPLE LEAVE.
AND NOTHING'S DONE EVEN IF THERE
IS A FINDING OF THE VERY FEW-INSTANCES.
SO THIS PARTICULAR.
BILL IS DESIGNED TO ADDRESS WHAT
WE SEE IS THAT IMPORTANT AS AS A
DEFICIENCY IN THE STATE PROCESS --
AND IT WILL ALLOW PEOPLE TO HAVE
A PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION AND I
THINK THIS IS THE BEST THING
ABOUT THIS BILL IS IT KEEPS
PEOPLE HONEST.
THERE'S OTHER STATE AGENCIES
THAT.
HAVE THE SIMILAR TYPE OF ACTION
AVAILABLE TO THEIR PLACE THEY
HAVEN'T COLLAPSED UNDER THE
SYSTEM AT ALL.
AND THERE'S NO MULTIMILLION
DOLLAR JUDGMENTS RUNNING AROUND
THAT LAST TIME WE CHECKED WE SAW.
THAT -- YOU KNOW THAT WOULD LEAD
US TO CONCLUDE MAYBE THIS ISN'T
THE BEST WAY TO DO IT.
BUT IT DOES KEEP PEOPLE HONEST
THAT IT AND IT TAKES THINGS OUT
OF THE HANDS.
OF A DEPARTMENT THAT RIGHT NOW
IS IN CHARGE OF THE WHOLE
PROCESS A PROVIDING REDRESS AND
IT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE WORKING
VERY EFFECTIVELY AT ALL
[inaudible]
MAJOR.
MY STATEMENT IS IS THAT OKAY.
YOU MAY YES I DO I JUST I HAVE
EVERYTHING WRITTEN OUT AND JUST
AND FEEL LIKE I WANT TO HAVE
EVERYTHING -- EVERYBODY ENOUGH
TIME OKAY OKAY I WOULD JUST LIKE.
OKAY.
MY NAME IS MAJOR TWENTY ONE I
USED TO BE A FORMER MEMBER OF IT --
CALIFORNIA AIR NATIONAL GUARD
RIDLEY FROM SAM CISCO ONE REYES
THERE WENT TO UCLA GRADUATED
WITH A BA IN WHEN THE STUDIES
HAVE A LAW DEGREE FROM RECORDS I
ALSO HAVE A SECOND LARGELY FROM
GOING TO UNIVERSITY.
AS PURSUING MY THIRD IN THE OUR
STOCK ACTUALLY IT WAS MY
DISSERTATION.
EVERYTHING HAS BEEN SAID HERE IS
ABSOLUTELY.
SPOT ON RETALIATION IN THE
CALIFORNIA SHUGART IS RAMPANT
AND IT'S IT'S PRACTICING
CONDONED BY.
THE VERY TOP MAJOR GENERAL
BALDWIN AND I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY HE'S STILL THERE.
AND SO I ENCOURAGE YOU PLEASE
[inaudible]
PLEASE. TO SUPPORT THE SPELL
BECAUSE LIVES HAVE BEEN RUINED --
NOT JUST A MILITARY PERSONNEL
THE CIVILIANS AS WELL CIVILIANS
HAVE LOST.
THEIR HOUSES.
BECAUSE OF US THEY WANT TO
REPORT SOMETHING.
YOU'RE GUARANTEED TO BE
RETALIATED [inaudible]
YOUR YOU'LL BE REMOVED FROM HER
JOB ANY EVENTUALLY KICKED OUT I
TESTIFIED AGAINST JOHN BALDWIN.
SEVEN YEARS AGO AND ALL TOSE
THINGS.
THAT WERE. TO THE SENATE AT THAT
AND STILL HAVEN'T BEEN FIXED.
AND ALL THOSE PEOPLE THOSE
TWELVE PEOPLE WHO WERE WHO --
TESTIFIED.
WERE ALL KICKED OUT.
ROB RETALIATED AGAINST AND NONE
OF US THE MILITARY PERSONNEL
NONE OF US GOT ANY.
OPPORTUNITY.
OF REPARATION.
AND SO I HIGHLY ENCOURAGE YOU --
TO SUPPORT THIS PASS ANYONE IN
THE AUDIENCE WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT DOES THIS BILL PLEASE
COME A MICROPHONE YES MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF MIKE MATIC --
CONSUMER WATCHDOG COUNSEL FOR
THEM -- PRIOR TO THAT HONORABLY
SERVED IN TWO BRANCHES OF OUR
MILITARY AND HAVE -- RETIRED
RECENTLY FROM THIRTEEN YEARS USA
A VICE PRESIDENT SENIOR COUNSEL
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE.
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE PROTECT.
THOSE THAT HAVE THE COURAGE TO
STAND UP.
AND SAY WHAT'S WRONG. TO STAND
UP AT A GREAT RISK TO THEMSELVES
THE POINT OUT.
MALFEASANCE MISFEASANCE.
SEXUAL PREDATORS.
AND PROFITEERING.
IF WE CAN'T DO THAT. TO THESE
PATRIOTS WELCOME TO TRUST ALSO
LIKE TO THANK COLONEL ON BERG
SENATOR UMBERG. FOR HAVING THE
COURAGE TO BRING THIS BILL UP
AGAIN HE HAS BEEN A A RANGER FOR
JUSTICE IN THIS AREA FOR YEARS
AND THAT WOULD LAST FOR YOUR-IPHONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN THE AUDIENCE TO
SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE ADDRESSED MICROPHONE
[inaudible]
CHART.
DID YOU WANT.
NO ONE ON THIS ISSUE YEAH OKAY
IN OPPOSITION.
OF CENTERS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
YOU KNOW AS I'VE INDICATED TO
THE AUTHOR OF THE PROBLEM WITH
THE WAY THIS IS BEEN PRESENTED.
IS TYPICALLY BILLS ARE AMENDED
COMING INTO COMMITTEE BY THE
AUTHOR COMMITTEE.
SEES THE HAS THE OPTION TO
PROPOSE AMENDMENTS FROM THE
DíAS THE RATHER ACCEPTED OR NOT.
THIS IS RATHER SOMEONE USING TO
DEAL WITH AN AMENDMENT COMING
FROM THE OTHER DIRECTION NUMBER.
ONE NUMBER TWO HAVING LOOKED AT
IT IS IS IT MY UNDERSTANDING.
OPPOSED AMENDMENT WITH RESPECT
TO THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION.
ONLY EXTENDS TO WHISTLEBLOWER
REPRISAL.
GENOM [inaudible]
OKAY.
IS IT NOT DOES IT EXTEND TO THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION EXTENDED
TO THOSE ACCUSED.
OF REAP OF REPRISAL.
WHO WERE IN TITLE TEN STATUS?
DOES IT EXTEND TO THOSE WHO WERE
ACCUSED OF REPRISAL IN TITLE
THIRTY TWO STATUS.
IF ONLY IF THERE.
ONLY IF THEY'RE ACTING IN THEIR
STATE CAPACITY STATE PART OF THE
STATE MILITIA BUT THEIR MOTHER
THAT'S CONFUSING TO ME BECAUSE
MY UNDERSTANDING IS TOTAL
[inaudible]
THIRTY TWO FEDERALLY FUNDED.
STATE RELATED ACTIVITY FOR WHICH
AN INDIVIDUAL RECEIVES FOR
RETIREMENT CREDITS IS NOT NOT
THE CASE -- IS GREATER SO TITLE
THIRTY TWO TITLE.
TEN PERFORMING THE SAME GENERAL
TYPE OF DUTY DOES IT ALSO EXTEND
TO THOSE ACCUSED OF REPRISAL WHO
RUN STATE ACTIVE DUTY.
IT IS ACTIVE SO YOU AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS OF AN
INDIVIDUAL MALE OR FEMALE IN THE
GUARD COULD BE ON TITLE TEN
STATUS ONE WEEK FOR EXAMPLE.
DEPENDING ON THE ORDERS AND AND
HOW THEIR PHRASED AND MAYBE THE
FUNDING SOURCE.
AND THEN STATE IT CALLED THE
STATE ACTIVE DUTY BY THE
GOVERNOR ON THE STATE PAYROLL IF
THERE IS A A RIDE OR SOME OTHER
STATE ACTIVITIES NEEDS ATTENTION
IS THAT CORRECT.
THEY DID AND THAT YOU'RE RIGHT
THERE ARE OFTEN MULTIPLE
CAPACITIES SOURCE OR ONE OR TWO
CAPACITIES THAT A PERSON'S
ACTING IN AT A GIVEN TIME.
SO.
SO THE INDIVIDUAL WHO COULD BE
POTENTIALLY.
SUSCEPTIBLE TO A PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION.
DEPENDING ON THE STATUS IT THERE.
WHEN THEY TAKE THEIR THEIR THAT
ACTION CORRECT?
SIR -- IT IS AS YOU POINTED OUT
THAT'S THAT'S PRIMARILY DRIVEN
BY THE ORDERS IN THE FUNDING
SOURCE THAT CLEAR FROM THIS.
THIS AMENDMENT IN B. I CAN'T
TELL.
AYE AYE THE SIR I WOULD OFFER
THAT -- AS A STATE STATUTE IT
CAN ONLY EXTEND ACTUALLY -- TO
THE JURISDICTION OF THE STATE
LEGISLATURE THE STATE.
WAS IN THE MILITARY BETTER AT AS
A JUST JUST RESPOND ESPERANZA
POINT FOR POINT THAT AND WE WILL
CLARIFY THAT TITLE. THIRTY TWO
IF THERE'S DISCIPLINARY ACTION
TAKEN HAS THAT TAKEN.
SAID TAKEN IN THE STATE YOU SEEM
STATE VERSION OF THE UCMJ OR
UNDER THE UCMJ.
IT'S THE THE STATE -- WELL YOU
SEE A DAYS ADOPTED.
BYE BYE.
BUT YOUR DISCIPLINARY ACTION. TO
THE EXTENT THE ME MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE ALL CLEAR TO THE EXTENT
THAT THERE'S A A CRIME COMMITTED
WHILE IN STATE ACTIVE DUTY
STATUS. ONE WOULD BE COURT
MARTIALED IN THE STATE SYSTEM
VERSUS THE FEDERAL SYSTEM
ALTHOUGH THE UC M. J. -- AS
IMPLEMENTED BY THE STATE AS I
UNDERSTAND IT IT IS.
NEARLY IDENTICAL -- BUT THE
PROSECUTION WOULD HAPPEN WITHIN
THE STATE SYSTEM SO IT IS A
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION ORDER
CREW REQUIRE A SUBSTANTIATED.
A I G. COMPLAINT FINDING TO THE
EXTNT THAT AN IG COMPLAINT WAS
AN ISSUE.
SIR DOES NOT SO YOU COULD HAVE A
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION AFTER
YOU'VE HAD A STATE OR FEDERAL IG
COMPLAINT.
INVESTIGATION CONDUCTED AN
UNSUBSTANTIATED COMPLAIN FINDING
ISSUE.
YES.
I MEAN TO TO BE SPECIFIC JUST AS
IF THE PERPETRATOR AT LEAST THE
PURPORTED OR ALLEGE PERPETRATOR.
WERE SOME MILLION.
IF.
THE CIVILIAN IF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL DIDN'T INSPECTION.
THEN INVESTIGATION AND
DETERMINED THAT THE CLAIM WAS
UNFOUNDED.
AND SOMEONE DECIDED TO FILE A
CIVIL ACTION AGAINST THAT
CIVILIAN MY UNDERSTAND WE'RE
TALKING BUT MILITARY UNIFORMS.
THEY COULD BUT JUST AND
SIMILARLY AS TO SOMEONE WHO'S IN
STATE ACTIVITY.
BUT BUT YOUR POINT IS WELL TAKEN
AND CERTAINLY WE CLARIFY HERE.
THAT THIS PERTAINS TO STATE
ACTIVE DUTY TO THE EXTENT THAT
THE STOCK STILL EXIST.
IN SHOULD SOMEONE FOR EXAMPLE
THERE IS ONLY APPLIES TO TITLE.
TEN ON ITS FACE YES YES AND IT
HAS BEEN.
ADDRESSED BY A STATE COURT
DECISION AMONG OTHERS AS AS TO
HOW IT IS TO BE INTERPRETED AND
THAT'S THAT'S WRAPPED AROUND
FEDERAL TORT CLAIMS ACT AND
ALTERNATIVE BENEFITS AND
DISABILITY BENEFITS AND THERE'S
A LONG HISTORY WHETHER IT'S
CORRECT OR NOT.
AND WHETHER IT'S BEEN APPLIED%
PROPERLY AND IT'S BEHIND THIS
FERRIS ISSUE IN THESE FERRIES
ARGUMENTS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
PROBABLY GONNA BE ADDRESSED
AGAIN.
BY THE UNITED STATES SUPREME
COURT THAT'S NOT.
FAIRS DOESN'T APPLY TO SOMEONE
IN STATE CORRECT ACTIVE DUTY
STATUS WORKING A RIOT IN LOS
ANGELES RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY SO.
IF I MIGHT ANSWER THE EIGHT THAT
DECISION ACTUALLY EVEN POINT OUT
THE ESPYS VERSUS MONROE DECISION
A ACTUALLY POINTED OUT OF THIRD
DCA OPINION SACRAMENTO.
THAT -- THEY WANT TO APPROACH
THIS THE SAME WAY THE FAIRIES
COURT ACTUALLY REACH THE ISSUE
AND THAT WAS IN GREAT STERN
BEGAN AND ENDED -- FUNDAMENTALLY
WITH THE AND INTERPRETATION.
OF THE STATUTORY SCHEME.
BY LATE SO HAVE SWIMMING IS ONE
OTHER QUESTION.
SOMEBODY TELL E WHAT WHAT IS
BROKEN ABOUT THE WHAT I THINK IS
THE EXISTING SYSTEM.
SO IF YOU HAVE A WHISTLE BLOWER
OR REPRISAL CLIMB.
DOESN'T THAT ULTIMATELY GO TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE.
INSPECTOR GENERAL FOR A REPRISAL
INVESTIGATION.
CAN I JUST WOMAN FIVE IF IF
YOU'RE QUALIFIED DANCE YES YES
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN THROUGH IT.
OKAY AND SO -- FIRST OF ALL I
WANT YOU TO UNDERSTAND THAT
NINETY NINE POINT 99% OF AYE TWO
COMPLAINTS.
ARE NEVER SUBSTANTIATED.
EVER BECAUSE YOU HAVE THE FLOCK
[inaudible]
YOU HAVE.
IF.
YOU HAD ASKED THAT QUESTION
EARLIER SO I JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY I I'D LIKE THE ANSWER TO
THE QUESTION HAVING TO DO WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE.
PROCESS.
FOR ROOF IDYLLWILD SOMETHING
I'VE FOUGHT WITH THE DOD IG
WHICH I DID ARE THEY
AUTOMATICALLY.
REPORTED TO THE DOD INSPECTOR
GENERAL IF IT INVOLVES.
WHISTLE BLOWER AND REPRISAL
ALLEGATIONS.
ACTUALLY IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
OF THAT THIS.
AMONG OTHER THINGS ACTUALLY AS A
WHISTLEBLOWER REPRISAL ACT.
BUT I MEAN YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH
THE SYSTEM RIGHT.
ARE THERE ARE WOULD WHISTLE
BLOWER WHISTLE BLOWER AND
REPRISAL ALLEGATIONS.
DIRECTLY REPORTED.
EITHER THROUGH THIS.
STATE IG OR THE FEDERAL AYE
INSPECTOR GENERAL HERE IN
CALIFORNIA OR THE ADJUTANT
GENERAL. TO THE DEPARTMENT TO
THE IN THIS CASE I GUESS IT
WOULD BE THE SECRETARY OF ARMY
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
AND THEN ON TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE IG FOR PURPOSES OF
TRACKING REVIEW.
APPROVAL BECAUSE OF THE
SENSITIVITY OF REPRISAL CASES AS
EARLY TO UNDERSTAND NOT
NECESSARILY.
IT IS REPORTED AYE I UNDERSTAND --
BUT AND CRACKED BUT THE
INVESTIGATION AND BE ACTUALLY
COMPLETED STRICTLY WITH.
SO GIVEN THE FACT THAT THERE IS
A PROCESS.
THAT EXTENDS FROM THE STATE.
OF THROUGH THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT PENTAGON.
AND TO THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE
WHAT'S BROKEN ABOUT THAT PROCESS --
I THINK THE OF MANIFESTATION IF
I THINK IT MAY NOT BE BROKEN ON
IT SPACE IN THE SENSE OF THE
ARCHITECTURE OF IT SIR.
YEAH BUT I MEAN THE ORIGINAL
INTENT OF THE REGULATORY SCHEME.
BUT I THINK WHAT WERE REFERRING
TO AND WHAT THIS BILL IS DUE
ADDRESSES THAT IS OUR ACTUALLY
FUNCTION.
IN A WAY THAT I THINK THE
WITNESS WAS EXPRESSING FOR OUR
OWN PERSPECTIVE.
YOU KNOW WHAT ARE THE THE THE
FAILURE TO ACTUALLY FUNCTION AS
INTENDED.
AND AND WHETHER THAT'S BECAUSE
OF MILITARY OVERSIGHT TO COME
HAVE AN I. G.'S BY THE ARMY
REGULATIONS -- ARE REPORTABLE.
AND REPORT DIRECTLY TO THE
COMING.
AND SO TO THE EXTENT THERE'S NOT
A COMMAND -- WELL -- AND THE
SUBORDINATE LEVEL THE PENTAGON
THE IG WORKS WITH SECRETARY HAS
CORRECT RIGHT AND ACTUALLY THAT
IS A DISTINCTION BETWEEN THE
FEDERAL ID.
SYSTEM THERE ARE VARIOUS --
STANDARD FOR THE I NEED TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE INDEPENDENT ACT OF
THE D. O. D. COMMANDER -- WHICH
DOESN'T EXIST AT STATE LEVEL SO
THIS AT STATE LEVEL THE DATA
THAT STATE IG -- ACTUALLY -- I I
THINK EVEN THAT -- THE CASE OF
OF MAJOR STERLING THAT --
EVERYONE MAY BE FAMILIAR WITH --
POINTED OUT THAT COURT I'VE GOT
A COPY OF THAT I CAN READ THE
BILL LANGUAGE POINT OUT THAT --
THE IN THE STATE I G. SYSTEM THE
STATE I. G. -- REPRISAL COMPLAIN
ONLY NEEDS TO DO THREE OF THE
SEVEN ACID TESTS CORRECT WHEREAS
THE DOD IG WOULD DO ALL SEVEN
AND SO -- I THINK THAT THE
ARCHITECTURE OF THE DAY YOU'RE
GOING TO SERVE SEEMS LIKE IT
WOULD BE COMPREHENSIVE.
BUT THE ACTUAL -- IMPLEMENTATION
THE THE ACT WILL PERFORMANCE OF
WELL LET ME TELL YOU HERE'S MY
PROBLEM.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE BEEN THERE
MAY BE A WAY TO WORK AROUND THIS
WITH RESPECT TO THOSE FOLKS WHO
RUN THE STATE MILITIA WHO NEVER
PERFORMED.
TITLE TENER TITLE.
THIRTY TO A DUTY.
WHETHER THEY'RE VOLUNTEER OR
THERE IF THERE ARE SOME THAT ARE
PAID -- I HAVE A PROBLEM HAVING
ONE PERSON THE SAME PERSON
SUBJECT TO A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION OR NOT DEPENDING ON WHAT
SET OF ORDERS THEY GET.
AND WHO'S PAYING FOR THE DUTY.
NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO I HAVE A
PROBLEM.
SUBJECTING A MILITARY MEMBER TO
A PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION.
WHEN IF THERE IS AN IG
INVESTIGATION AND A REPORT THE
INVESTIGATION FINDS THE
COMPLAINT UNSUBSTANTIATED AND
THEN WE SUBJECT THE MILITARY
MEMBER TO AN OUTSIDE PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION IN A SUPERIOR
COURT WITH A WHOLE BUNCHOF
ATTORNEYS?
AND I'VE AS THE OFF THROUGH THE
QUESTION IN THE FACE OF AN
UNSUBSTANTIATED FINDING BY A IG
STATE OR FEDERAL WOULD NOT THE
STATE HAVE AN OBLIGATION AT THAT
POINT TO AT LEAST PROVIDE A
DEFENSE.
IF NOT AN INDEMNITY DEPENDING ON
THE RESULT -- IN THE DEPENDING
ON THE RESULTS I HAVE A PROBLEM
ON THOSE TWO LEVELS -- I THINK
ULTIMATELY -- IN A DIFFERENT
SETTING WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO WORK
THIS OUT SO THAT -- THE OFFICERS
THE YOUNG OFFICERS CONCERNS ARE
ADDRESSED YOU KNOW UNFORTUNATELY
THERE ARE.
MANY PEOPLE AROUND THE MILITARY
SYSTEM WHO RUN SATISFIED BY IG.
INVESTIGATIONS IN THE MOST
SENSITIVE CASES OBVIOUSLY WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PROCESS WORKS.
BUT THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S DO
THEIR JOB FREE OF INFLUENCE BY
ANYBODY -- AND APPROPRIATE
DISCIPLINARY ACTION IS TAKEN AND
WE FROM MY PERSPECTIVE AT SOME
POINT WE CAN REVISIT THIS PRIDE
OF RIGHT OF ACTION.
UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES I THAT
I'VE OUTLINED WHICH IS FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE I DON'T SPEAK FOR
THE CHAIR.
BUT WERE YOU TALK ABOUT STRICTLY
STATE PEOPLE DOING STRICTLY
STATE STUFF WHO DON'T CROSS OVER
AND THE TITLE TEN TITLE THIRTY
TWO AREA.
PERFORM MILITARY MISSIONS UNDER
THE FEDERAL PAYROLL FOR FOR
RETIREMENT.
AND THAT'S ACTUALLY -- WELL WHY
IN MY OPENING COMMENTS ARE I I
WAS I SUGGEST I THINK -- THE THE
BEST APPROACH BUT AS PRIDE RIGHT
RIGHT OF ACTION IS TO DEFINE IT.
SEPARATELY SO THAT IT WOULD
ADDRESS THOSE VERY CONCERNS AND
I THINK THAT CAN BE DONE FRANKLY
EVEN BY -- AMENDMENTS TO THIS
LINE CHAU I'M NOT SURE THIS IS
THE RIGHT PLACE YOUR TIME BUT
THOSE ARE MY COMMENTS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU M. THANK YOU GENERAL
VERY MUCH FOR DOING THAT I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU ANSWERED A
LOT OF QUESTIONS.
AT THAT GENERAL THIRD SENATOR
ROTH HAD ASKED REGARDING THE I.
G. IN THE APPEAL PROCESS TO THE
DOD AND REGARDING TITLE THIRTY
THIRTY TWO ENTITLED TEN SO I
APPRECIATE THOSE QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
SO -- I'D LIKE TO TAKE IT A STEP
FURTHER THAN WHAT SENATOR ROTH
DID -- AND IDENTIFY LANGUAGE IT
SAYS.
YOU KNOW STATE PEOPLE AT STATE
TIME EXCLUSIVELY AND STATE
PEOPLE ITS STATE TIME YOU'RE
STILL IMPLEMENTING A PRIVATE
RIGHT ACTION AGAINST A MILITARY
SERVICE MEMBER.
WHO HAS BEEN CLEARED OR HAS AN
AND SINCE AND SHE TO CLAIM FROM
THE IG?
AND IS THAT THE INTENT OF YOUR
BILL [inaudible]
WELL.
A COUPLE ITEMS HERE.
OFFERS LET ME RESPOND TO SENATOR
OFF YOUR SERVICER OFF YOU'VE
YOU'VE REYES GOOD POINTS -- AND
AND SO.
IN WHAT WAYS THE I HAVE BEEN
HAVE BEEN HERE LONG ENOUGH THAT
SO FAR ALL GOOD POINTS -- IN
TERMS OF FURTHER DEFINITION YOUR
POINT'S WELL TAKEN IN AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE COMMITTEE ALLOWS
US TO GO FORWARD.
WE WILL DRILL DOWN TO DEFINE
WHERE THAT PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION.
CAN BE IMPLEMENTED CERTAINLY IT
DOESN'T -- IF SOMEONE'S PROTECT
BY THE FAIRS DOCTRINE THEY
ALLEGE THAT IN THEIR PROTECTED
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOMEONE IS
CLEARED BY THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
YOUR QUESTION.
CENTER ROAD SYSTEM DIXON
SOMEONE'S CLEARED BY THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
OF JUST AS A CIVILIAN YOU CAN
FILE I MEAN YOU YOU CAN FILE A
LAWSUIT AGAINST THE PERSON IF
YOU THINK THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
HAS DONE.
EITHER AN INCOMPLETE INADEQUATE
OR DIDN'T COVER ALL THE BASES
AND YOU THINK YOU'VE STILL BEEN
WRONG AND YOU'VE BEEN DAMAGED
IT'S WORTH IT TO YOU TO ACTUALLY
MOVE FORWARD AND YOU FIND A
COUNCIL.
IT'S WORTH IT FOR HIM OR HER TO
TO EITHER.
PUT THEIR TIME ON THE LINE TO GO
FORWARD.
THEN JUST AS IT WERE WITH THE
CIVILIAN YOU CAN MOVE OR I THINK
IT'S UNLIKELY BUT BUT WE
SHOULDN'T PROVIDE I MY VIEW WE
SHOULD NOT PROVIDE.
THE PROTECTION FOR SOMEONE WHO
HARASSES LET ME JUST GIVE YOU A
SPECIFIC EXAMPLE.
OF SOMEONE URINATES IN SOMEONE
ELSE'S BOOTS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
INTIMIDATING THEM.
AND THEN IT'S REPORTED THAT
THERE IS AN ISSUE WITH RESPECT
TO THE COMMAND.
PERSON WEATHER IS THE PERSON
WHO'S BOOT SAID BEEN URINATED
UPON OR WHETHER IT'S ANOTHER
PERSON WHO'S TRYING.
TO UNRAVEL WHATEVER'S GOING ON
THE COMMAND THAT WOULD.
PROVIDE FOR THAT ENVIRONMENT.
IN THEIR RETALIATE AGAINST THE
PERSON WHO DOES THE RETALIATION
MERELY BECAUSE THEY'RE IN A
UNIFORM SHOULD NOT BE GIVEN ANY
GREATER PROTECTIONS.
THEN A CIVILIAN. EIGHT OFFICER
IN THE MILITARY NON COMMISSIONED
OFFICER OR ENLISTED PERSON WHO
HARASSES AND I'M GONNA SAY A
WOMAN SHOULD NOT BE PROTECTED.
ANY MORE THAN A CIVILIAN.
THEY SHOULD FACE THE SAME CIVIL
CONSEQUENCES NOW THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL CONCLUDES THAT THERE WAS
NO WRONGDOING MY GUESS IS THEY
DON'T FILE LAWSUITS BUT IF THE
PERSON BELIEVES THAT THEY'RE
SOMEHOW INADEQUATE.
THEN THEN IT'S THE IT'S THE SAME
STATUS IT'S THE SAME STATUS.
WE SHOULD NOT BE WE AS A
LEGISLATURE WE AS A STATE THIS
ADMINISTRATION SHOULD NOT BE IN
THE POSITION OF PROTECTING.
THOSE WHO RUN STATE MILITARY
DUTY SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY'RE
WEARING UNIFORMS.
AND I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING SIR I REALLY DO BUT I'M
JUST MY ISSUE IS IS THAT WE HAVE
A CHAIN OF COMMAND TO ME OF
UNITED STATES MILITARY RIGHT
THAT IT IT HERE'S TO A CHAIN OF
COMMAND.
IT'S INVESTIGATED COMPLAINTS ARE
BY INSPECTOR GENERAL THAT HAS AN
APPEAL PROCESS TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE ON THE FEDERAL SIDE
EVEN IF ITS TITLE TEN ISSUES.
SO THERE IS A AN APPEAL PROCESS
IN SO I GUESS.
I THINK THERE'S ADEQUATE
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE TO GO ALL
THE WAY TO THE FEDERAL LEVEL IF
NEED BE IF SOMEONE HAD A
COMPLAINT.
AND SO I DO I I HAVE A HUGE
ISSUE WITH THAT BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THEY'RE SEPARATE I DO
BELIEVE THEY'RE SEPARATE AND I
UNDERSTAND SAME THE SAME.
CONCESSIONS AS A PRIVATE CITIZEN
BUT TO CREATE A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION IN A MILITARY SCENARIO
WHERE THERE IS A COMMANDCENTER.
AND YOU TAKE THINGS OUT OF THE
CHAIN OF COMMAND CASTING CONTROL
YOU ALSO.
REMOVE THE APPEAL PROCESS EVEN
INSPECTOR GENERAL WHO DOES THEIR
DUE DILIGENCE AND IS A COMPLETE
INVESTIGATION.
FINDS NO FINDINGS OR AND YOU
KNOW WE'RE ENTITIES TO
INSTANTIATE A COMPLAINT.
AND THEN IF THEY WANTED TO
APPEAL TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE THEY FIND IT NO FINDINGS
ON A SUBSTANTIATED COMPLAINT AND
THEN YOU STILL HAVE A
RETALIATORY MECHANISM.
MOST PEOPLE IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR JUST SETTLE TO GET RID OF
IT SO LET'S GO THERE.
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR THERE'S A
PART OF THE PRIVATE ATTORNEY
GENERAL ACT IN THOSE ATTORNEYS A
FILE THOSE LAWSUITS GET ABOUT
33240%.
OF THE CASE SETTLEMENT WHAT'S
THE PERCENTAGE THAT YOU WOULD
GET AS AN ATTORNEY FROM THE DOT
UNLESS YOU MISTER BLISS HARM
HARMLESS YES.
GO AHEAD AND SAY THAT OVER TIME
AND THAT IN CASH WHAT'S YOUR THE
PROCESS I'M SURE YOU TAKE IT ON
A CONTINGENCY.
I DON'T KNOW I'VE NEVER TAKEN IN
THOSE CASES NEVER TAKEN THIS.
ONE OF YOUR CLIENTS NO SHE'S NOT
HE IS NOT.
AT UC GENERAL BALD AND HOW MANY
TIMES.
I THINK THREE OR THREE THREE
HAVE YOU BEEN SUCCESSFUL AND I
HAVE NOT.
SO THAT'S ANOTHER THING THAT
BOTHERS ME IS THAT THE LAWS IN
PLACE AND THERE ARE LAWS IN
PLACE WHERE INSPECTOR CHEN HAS
IN LET ME GO THERE HAS INSPECTOR
GENERAL.
ON THE CASES THAT YOU'VE SO
GENERAL BALDING AND HAVE THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL PROVIDED AND
SUBSTANTIATED COMPLAINTS OR AN
INVESTIGATION.
ENTER ONE ONE THING FIRST.
SOME OF THE RECENT REPORTS FROM
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL TO
CONGRESS.
SHOW THAT 90% OF THE REPRISAL
COMPLAINTS THEY RECEIVE.
SOMEWHERE IN THAT AREA BETWEEN
8090% OR MORE.
OUR CLOTHES WITHOUT AN
INVESTIGATION.
THEY JUST CLOSE THEM.
THEY'RE NOT INVESTIGATED.
SEVENTIES INVESTIGATED HIM.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT WILL --
REPORTING THAT THEIR CLOTHES
WITHOUT INVESTIGATION.
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS IN
TERMS OF WHAT THEY'VE ACTUALLY
DONE TO CLOSE IT.
DIDN'T SEND ANYBODY AROUND ASK
QUESTIONS.
AND THE REASON THAT WE'RE HERE
IS THE WHOLE SYSTEM IS BROKEN
DOWN IN THAT RESPECT.
YOU HAVE THE ABILITY IF THE
INVESTIGATE IF THE ID DOESN'T DO
THE INVESTIGATION DISCRETION.
IT'S DISCRETIONARY IT IS. TO GO
TO THE DOT IF THEY TAKE IT UP IS
DISCRETIONARY THEY DON'T HAVE TO
TAKE IT UP.
AND WHEN THE MAJOR IS HERE SHE'S
MADE A COMMENT THAT NINETY NINE
POINT 99%
OF I. G. COMPLAINTS.
THE G. SAID NINETY NINE POINT
99% OF I. G. COMPLAINTS.
DON'T FALL IN FAVOR OF THE
PLAINTIFF I THINK THE REPRISAL
COMPLACENT STAINED BY THE DOD
ARE AROUND 1% SOMEWHERE IN THAT
AREA.
DO YOU HAVE DOCUMENTATION I CAN
PROVIDE THAT YOUR OFFICE I WOULD
BE HAPPY TO GIVE YOU WHAT I HAVE
I DON'T HAVE IT WITH ME.
OKAY SO I LIKE I SAID I HAVE A
HUGE ISSUE -- I REALLY DO HAVE A
HUGE ISSUE WITH THE STATE
INTERFERING WITH THE MILITARY
COMMAND THAT HAS AN APPEAL
PROCESS TO THE DOD I AND I'M A
FEMALE VETERAN ON THE FIRST
FEMALE VETERAN THAT'S EVER
SERVED IN THIS BUILDING.
SO I GET IT AND AND YOU KNOW I'M
NOT THE CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE
BUT I'M THE BY STEERING AND I
WOULD REALLY GAS THAT YOU'RE NOT
TO ACCEPT THESE AMENDMENTS.
AND I WOULD SUPPORT THE TERROR
NOT ACCEPTING LIMITED BECAUSE TO
DO THAT SIR.
ANY OTHER COMMENT NO SIR.
I'D LIKE [inaudible]
TO WELL.
FIRST ALTHOUGH THE HAVE.
CENTER THE BOOT CASE THAT YOU
REFERENCED.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THE PROBLEM --
IN IN TOTAL IF NOT AT LEAST IN
LARGE PART WASTHAT THE INITIAL
INVESTIGATION WAS A COMMANDER
DIRECTED INVESTIGATION.
UNDER THE INHERENT AUTHORITY OF
THE COMMANDER THAT WAS --
PERHAPS MISHANDLED AND THAT WAS
THE MATTER WAS ELEVATED TO THE
STATE IG IN THE FEDERAL IG IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THINGS STARTED TO HAPPEN
INCLUDING THE RELIEF OF OFFICERS
AND INVESTIGATIONS IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING ARE STILL ON GOING.
I WOULDN'T WANT ANYBODY IN THE
AUDIENCE HERE.
THAT THERE WAS ANYTHING OTHER
THAN THAT.
BUT I THINK THERE'S A PATH
FORWARD HERE FOR YOU I THINK THE
PATH FORWARD IS.
TO KEEP THIS BILL LIVE IS TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS
WHICH DO NOT INCLUDE PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION.
AND THEN WORK FOR WORK WITH THE
FOLKS IN ON THE COMMITTEE HERE
AS A MOVES OUT OF THE COMMITTEE
TO SEE IF THERE IS A A PATH TO
CRAFT LANGUAGE AS YOU WERE.
WHEN THIS YEAR INDICATED TO DEAL --
SPECIFICALLY WITH PEOPLE WHO
NEVER SERVED IN A TITLE TENER
IDLE RUDY TO STATUS.
WHO WERE STRICTLY ON?
THE EQUIVALENT OF STATE
EMPLOYEES I'M NOT SURE THAT WE
CAN GET HER I'M NOT SURE I CAN.
BUT I'M CERTAINLY.
WILLING TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION BUT THE ALTERNATIVE
IS. TO TO DO GO DOWN THE PATH
YOU'RE GOING SO THAT'S UP TO YOU
THAT THOSE ARE THE ONLY COMMENTS
[inaudible]
NORTHERN HOMAGE [inaudible]
MERS.
SO THE SENATE RATHER I I ACCEPT
YOUR SUGGESTION I THINK THAT'S A
WISE IDEA AND IF THAT'S
ACCEPTABLE TO CHEER WHAT I I'VE
I WOULD.
ACCEPT THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
WE WON'T INCLUDE THE PARTICULAR
ONE THAT'S AT ISSUE RIGHT NOW --
I DON'T WANT TO BE.
A DISINGENUOUS SO IT'S AN AREA
WHERE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK IN
AND WILL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE -- IF THERE'S ANY
SIGNIFICANT SUBS OF CHANGE FROM
THE POINT IN TIME WHEN IT LEAVES
THE COMMITTEE.
BUT LET ME RESPOND TO SENATOR
GROW.
THIS IS SORT OF AN APPLES AND
ORANGE THING -- FIRST AS THE
GERMAN BOB.
I KNOW ONLY THE GENERAL BALDWIN
IS AN EFFECTIVE HONORABLE
OFFICER THIS IS NOT ABOUT
GENERAL BONUS ON ABOUT APRIL.
SIR IN THE NATIONAL GUARD -- SO-I WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S THAT'S CLEAR.
ENOUGH [inaudible]
WELL THE SENATOR -- BECAUSE
SOMEONE APPEARS AS A WITNESS
DOES NOT MEAN NECESSARILY THAT
THAT THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
ADOPTS WHATEVER VIEWS WHATEVER
WHATEVER BEHAVIORS AND AND I
ASSUME YOU KNOW THAT SO.
SO WHAT WILL PUT THAT ASIDE.
BUT THE ISSUE WITH RESPECT -- TO
WHETHER OR NOT THE MILITARY
TAKES ACTION CERTAINLY THE
MILITARY CAN AND SHOULD TAKE
ACTION ANDERSON ISSUE CONCERNING.
ANY SORT OF IMPROPRIETY.
BUT BUT THAT DOESN'T.
THAT DOESN'T DEAL WITH THE ISSUE
OF SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN HARMED
ND IS SEEKING REDRESS FOR THAT
HARM.
SO FIRST I GET THIS DOES NOT
INCLUDE MEDICAL MALPRACTICE.
AND THAT'S A WHOLE DIFFERENT
ISSUE.
BUT WHAT THE FIRST DOCTOR IN.
IS IS PREMISED UPON THE MILITARY
BASICALLY IS IS SOVEREIGN.
SO WHEN SOMEONE IN THE DANIELS
CASE WHEN SOMEONE.
DIES IN CHILDBIRTH THROUGH GROSS
MALPRACTICE.
AND SOMEONE IS HARMED THE CHILD
FOR EXAMPLES LEFT WITH A
LIFELONG INJURY.
AND YOU CAN'T RECOVER THAT IS ON
JUST IN CALIFORNIA.
IF A WOMAN AND I'LL AND I'LL
POINT TO A WOMAN IF A WOMAN HAS
BEEN HARM BECAUSE OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
BESIDES THE WHATEVER
ADMINISTRATIVE OR CRIMINAL
ACTION MAY BE TAKEN AGAINST THE
PERPETRATOR.
MY VIEW IS THAT WOMAN SHOULD
HAVE A RIGHT TO RECOVER FOR
WHATEVER INJURY SHE SUSTAINED
IRRESPECTIVE OF WHETHER THE
PERSON WHO PERPETRATED THAT.
WRONGDOING IS IN UNIFORM OR NOT
I TAKE YOUR POINT CONCERNING
WHETHER THERE'S AN
UNSUBSTANTIATED OR SUBSTANTIATE
AND WE CAN CERTAINLY WORK ON
THAT BUT IT'S REALLY.
THE SORT OF APPLES AND ORANGES
YEAH YES.
YOU DON'T HAVE THAT MEDICAL
MALPRACTICE IN YOUR BILL CORRECT
OR NOT THE END I'M I'M USING
THAT FOR THE LESSER CAM
ILLUSTRATIVE PURPOSES IS
[inaudible]
TO ARMS THAT.
WHEN THE FERRIES DOCTRINE IS IN
PLACE?
THAT BASICALLY PROVIDES A CLOAK
OF IMMUNITY FOR MANY DIFFERENT
HARMS AND BECAUSE THE CALIFORNIA
AND I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THOSE
WHO ARE ON STATE ACTIVE DUTY
ACTUALLY PERFORM MEDICAL.
PROCEDURES AT LEAST NOT.
WE'RE GETTING OUR STATE IF THAT
RIGHT.
A CENTER RIGHT JUST ONE FINAL
COMMENT AS YOU MOVE IF IN FACT
YOU MOVE IN THE WAY YOU'VE
INDICATED YOU'RE GONNA MOVE HERE
WITH THE BILL AND YOU HAVE
FURTHER CONVERSATIONS.
WITH YOUR WITNESSES.
I DON'T HAVE THIS GOVERNMENT
CODE THAT DEFINES IMPROPER
GOVERNMENTAL ACTIVITY IN FRONT
OF ME SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT
SAYS.
BUT YOU WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
TOWARDS INNOCENCE -- JUST THINK
ABOUT OPENING THE BARN DOORS ON
NINE SELECTION FOR PROMOTIONS.
IN A NATIONAL GUARD IT HAS
TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE AND I
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE THE
STATE MALICIOUS.
SO IF YOU HAVE A FEW OF A LIST
OF YOU CLAIM WHISTLEBLOWER
REPRISAL.
AND AS A RESULT YOU CLAIM YOU
WERE PROMOTED THEN I GUESS IN IN
IN AFFECTING THIS WE WOULD
AUTHORIZE.
IN THE FACE OF A UNSUBSTANTIATED
IG COMPLAINT WE'D AUTHORIZE A
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION FOR NON
SELECTION FOR PROMOTION.
I WITH THE UNLESS THIS IS
SOMEHOW LIMITED SO I DON'T WANT
TO BELABOR THIS I'M JUST ASKING
YOU AS YOU MOVE FORWARD. TO
CONSIDER THAT.
LITTLE PIECE NINE SELECTION
ANYBODY FROM A SERGEANT. TO A I
GUESS OF ONE STAR GENERAL AS WE
ONLY HAVE A TWO FILES A CLAIM
FOR NINE SELECTION FOR PROMOTION
SO THERE YOU GO.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT WORKS.
I THINK THAT'S A POINT WELL
TAKEN.
MANY I'M GONNA GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY CLOSE AFTER -- MY
COMMENTS -- BUT WE'VE HEARD.
ALLOWED TO SENATOR TO BE ABLE.
TO RESPOND IN AND WITNESSES AND
SHAUN AND WE'VE GIVEN PLENTY OF
TIME.
I CANNOT SEE THIS GOING FORWARD
AS I SEE IT.
WHEN A SOLDIER HAS THE RIGHT TO
SUE ANOTHER SOLDIER AND I'LL ASK
ANY VETERAN OUT THERE YOU TELL
ME WHEN YOU SHOW?
OR HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO SUE
YOUR SERGEANT OR VICE VERSA IT'S
NEVER HAPPENED THE MILITARY CODE
OF JUSTICE HAD BEEN THERE.
SINCE DAY ONE AND ALL OF US IN
THE BY BY IT WE'VE ALL MAINTAIN
OUR LINE OF OF SEQUENCE WHETHER
IT'S THAT.
THE PRIVATE WORKING HIS WAY UP
TO TALK TO HIS COMMANDING
OFFICER OR A CAT IN COMMAND OR
WHATEVER BUT THERE WAS.
THERE WAS OF A POLICY IN PLACE
THE THE INSPECTOR GENERAL HAS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO LISTEN TAKE
ACTION.
AND EVERY SOLDIER.
SAILOR WHOEVER THEY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO KNOCK ON THAT
DOOR AND TALK TO THE EXPECTING.
TO THE INSPECTOR GENERAL SO WHEN
THIS OPENS THE DOOR WHERE THE
MILITARY CAN START SUING ONE
ANOTHER.
I I I THINK WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE GONNA OPEN UP THIS DOOR
AND WE'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
CLOSE.
AND THAT'S MY FEAR FACTOR AND
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL IS THERE --
THAT PROCESS HAS BEEN THERE --
OUR PROCEDURES IN THE MILITARY
BEEN THERE EVER SENT TO ALL OF
US WERE BORN AND IT BEFORE.
SO I I'M AFRAID WITH THIS IS
GOING TO DO AND A LOT OF GREAT
MEN AND WOMEN HAVE SERVED IN
DRAGON AND THEY'VE REPRESENTED
OUR OUR SOLDIERS.
WITH HONOR AND DIGNITY AND WHENTHERE IS A AN ISSUE ABOUT
REPRISAL AND SO ON I THINK THE
SYSTEM OVER THE YEARS THAT WE'VE
ALL SURE.
IT'S PROVEN RIGHT.
AND SO THERE MIGHT BE ISSUES
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD ISSUES WITH
THEIR COMMANDING OFFICERS BUT
THAT DOES NOT -- I BELIEVE GIVES
THE RIGHT TO THE CLEAN THE THE
ENTIRE SLATE.
THE MILITARY CODE OF JUSTICE IS
THERE FOR A REASON AND SO I'M
I'M GONNA HAVE TO SAY THAT -- WE
CAN'T CHANGE THAT AND I DON'T
WANT TO BEGIN TO CHANGE IT SO
WITH THAT I'M GONNA ALLOW YOU TO
CLOSE AND THEN I'M GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND AND AND CALL FOR THE
VOTE.
SO I WANT TO BE CLEAR RIGHT YES
YET WHAT WHAT WHAT I BELIEVE
YOU'RE VOTING ON IS I BELIEVE
YOU'RE VOTING ON THE BILL WITH
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS EXCEPT.
EXCEPT THE THE PROVISION THAT
YOU JUST REFERENCE MISTER CHAIR
EXCEPT -- TO BE VERY CLEAR
SECTION THREE FIFTY SIX ONE B.
SUBI AS IN BRAVO THAT WOULD NOT
BE INCLUDED IN THE BILL.
ALL THE OTHER AMENDMENTS THAT WE
HAD WORKED OUT WITH THE WITH THE
WITH THE STAFF WELL THE ONE I
WOULD.
STILL THE CODE OF ACTION.
IMAGES MISTER CHAIR OF THE SOAP
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS.
THERE WERE INCLUDING IN THE BILL
THAT WE'RE GOING TO VOTE ON ARE
THE PER COMMITTEES PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEE IN THE HOUSE.
THIS ONE HERE RIGHT.
RIGHT THIS IS THIS IS THE ONE WE
WANT IN THIS IS THE ONE WE WANT
OUT.
CHAU -- THE THE IF WE GO FORWARD
IT'S GOT TO BE WITH THIS ONE
IT'S NOT IT'S NOT WITH THE ONE
THAT YOU'VE YOU'VE YOU'VE
SUBMITTED IT'S THE LANGUAGE IN
THE COMMITTEES ANALYSIS TEST TO
YOUR BILL.
THEY'VE OUTLINED A COUPLE
AMENDMENTS THAT THERE WOULD
COMMITTEES WILLING TO ACCEPT.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GONNA
VOTER RIGHT RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO VOTE IN A GO.
EIGHT OUT WHEN WE VOTE ON THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT.
NO BE IS OUT I'LL BE IS OUT.
BROUGH IS OUT OKAY CLOSER SO
THOSE ARE HIS THOSE ARE WE
WORKING ON HIS DOCUMENTS.
IS THE PROBLEM OF WORKING IN
MEMBERS FROM THE DIE SO YES.
THE WELL LET ME MAKE A
SUGGESTION JUST AS A MEMBER.
I'M NOT WORKING ON ANYBODY'S
DOCUMENT OTHER THAN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS BECAUSE I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS BECAUSE
I HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO READ
IT SO AND THIS I'M LOOKING AT
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS OF YOU
ALL SITTING THERE.
NOW.
WE WON AND YOU HAVE A PROFIT SO
[inaudible]
LET ME.
IN ORDER IS IF YOU KNOW WHAT WE
SHOULD DO HERE'S HERE'S MY
SUGGESTION JUST TO BE ABSOLUTELY
CLEAR I THINK WE SHOULD COMPARE
DOCUMENTS IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT COMMITTEE ANALYSIS TO ME AS
THE CHIEF CONSULTANT.
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS BASICALLY
INCORPORATES EVERYTHING OTHER
THAN THE THE PARTICULAR
REFERENCE OF I MADE -- TO THE
SECTION. THREE FIFTY SIX POINT
ONE B. AS IN BRAVO IS THAT RIGHT.
OKAY STRENGTH BE RIGHT AND ADD --
AND SUBJECT TO UNIFORM TO UCMJ
AND DOES NOT SUBJECT TO THE SAME
DAY.
RIGHT.
SO BUT FOR THE VOICE OF DOUBT.
WHY DON'T WE ASK MISTER CHAIR
WHAT WHY DON'T I?
ASK THAT YOU PUT THIS OVER JUST
A MOMENT.
AND AND WE MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
VOTING ON WHAT WE THINK WE'RE
VOTING ON OKAY I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD AND SHOW YOU WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO VOTE ON ARE YOU CAN
APPRECIATE THAT.
THIS IS WHAT WHAT'S ON MY GO
RIGHT DOWN THE LINE -- EVERYBODY
UNDERSTAND THIS IS WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO STAY IN OF THE ANALYSIS
YOU SHOULD PROBABLY LOOK AT THE
ANALYSIS.
WE HAVE A LOOK -- I DO NOT HAVE
THE YOU KNOW.
NO THAT'S NOT IT.
OKAY IF I MIGHT [inaudible]
RIGHT HERE.
YES ALL ALL OF THAT BUT LET ME
LET ME I'M IN A CIRCLE IN BLUE.
WHAT IS NOT?
CONTAINED IN THE BILL AS MOVED
I'M GONNA SEND TO SEE -- ALSO WE
CAN SEE.
WHAT WHAT'S NOT CONTAINED IN THE
BILL I THINK IT'S IS MOTIONS SO?
BUT WE WILL THAT MEAN DOES THAT
MEAN YOU DON'T WANT THE WELL
JUST CIRCLE THEN WHAT I KNOW
WHEN I'VE CIRCLED IS IS WHAT I
UNDERSTAND THE AMENDMENTS
INCLUDE BUT THEY DO NOT INCLUDE
BE WHAT I JUST CIRCLE THERE NO.
YES THIS IS.
TO NOW THIS IS WHAT WE WANT TO
TAKE OUT THAT WE WANT TO PUT IN
HOUSE IS DIFFERENT. ONE EIGHT
I'M SORRY IN HIS PROPOSED
AMENDMENT YEAH I'M WE'RE WHAT
WE'RE YEAH SO YOU WANT A SO NO.
WE JUST.
WANT
[inaudible]
THE OKAY CENTER WE'RE GOING TO
GO HEAD AND PUT IT ON THE FLOOR
THAT WE'RE GOING TO AGREED -- TO
EXCEPT AMENDMENTS.
AND WITH THAT WILL CALL FOR THE
VOTE.
COMMITMENTS THE COMMITTEE
MEETING I WILL.
GROWTH I WILL MOVE THE BILL.
WITH THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS [inaudible]
GREAT -- FOR THE VOTE.
SENATE BILL FORTY ONE TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST REFERRED
PREPARATIONS ARCHULETA HI
ARCHULETA I GROW.
GROW I FOR TITLE [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
BROUGH.
I NUMBER HI I'M BURKE I WILL.
LOOK I THANK YOU ALL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
PLEASE [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
WILL CONTINUE LATER GERMAN WITH
THE SENATOR GLAZIER -- RUBIO.
I WOULD ON TWELVE WOULD LATER
FOR YEAH.
YEAH
.
THERE'S A REASON FOR THAT
THIS IS IF YOU TAKE PICTURES OF
EVERYBODY [inaudible]
JUST HERE.
PLEASE TAKE ONE PICTURE BEFORE
WE BEGAN [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
WE'RE OKAY WE'RE SPEAKING ABOUT
THE SENATE BILL -- SEVEN TWENTY
FIVE CENTER RUBIO PRESENT YOUR
BILL PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS A CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TODAY
I'M HERE PRESENTING SB SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE A BILL THAT WOULD
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA.
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS
TO ESTABLISH A RENTAL HOUSING
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM TO HELP
VETERANS ATTAIN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
CALIFORNIANS FACING A DIRE
HOUSING SHORTAGE WITH TWO POINT
TWO MILLION EXTREMELY LOW INCOME
AND VERY LOW INCOME RENTER
HOUSEHOLDS.
COMPETING FOR ONLY SO. SIX THE
FORTY THOUSAND AFFORDABLE RENTAL
HOMES THIS LEAVES MORE THAN ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION OF THEM OUT
OF CALIFORNIANS LOWEST INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS WITHOUT ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
FURTHERMORE CALIFORNIA.
RANKS TWENTY ONE OF THIRTY MOST
EXPENSIVE RENTAL HOUSING MARKETS
IN THE COUNTRY.
WHICH HAS AN ENORMOUS IMPACT ON
VETERANS WHO HAVE SERVED THEIR
COUNTRY AND ARE IN SEARCH OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
ACCORDING TO THE UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS
ELEVEN THOUSAND OF THE NATION'S
HOMELESS VETERANS LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA.
ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES FACING
VETERANS THE NUMBER OF OUR
HOMELESS VETERANS WILL CONTINUE
TO RISE.
SB SEVEN TWENTY FIVE WILL DIRECT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
VETERAN AFFAIRS TO ESTABLISH.
RENTAL HOUSING ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM FOR VETERANS SEEKING
RENTAL HOUSING BASED ON VETERAN
NEEDS HERE WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY AS TONY WE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION.
GOT AN INTERN SANDERS TWENTY
BOLIVIA CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION.
NUSSBAUM LONG DAYS KEEP IT BRIEF --
AS A CENTER OUTLINED WE ALL KNOW
THAT THERE'S A CALIFORNIA FACE
CHALLENGES FINDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ARE STRUGGLING WITH
HOMELESSNESS IN THE EXTREME
CASES.
THIS ON PRESS UNPRECEDENTED
HOUSING AND HOME WAS CRISIS IS
LARGELY CAUSED BY.
THE SERVER LACK OF NEW HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION ALL LEVELS
AFFORDABILITY.
THAT SAID.
A CRISIS LIKE THIS -- MERIT
SPECIAL CONSIDERATION OF
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR VETERANS --
SB THREE SB SEVEN TWO FIVE DOES
JUST THAT FOR BUTTONS BY
REQUIRING CALVET TO PROVIDE THIS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING ASSISTANCE TO
HELP THEM FIND.
A RENTAL HOUSING IN THE STATE.
YESTERDAY I BOUGHT THANKS.
WERE YOU GUYS PICK UP.
OKAY -- LET'S SEE ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL COMPORT
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PAT RAN OUT
THERE AND READ A SOCIO TRIP
WITHIN THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
RENTAL HOUSING ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
ON A WHEELCHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JEFF BURGER
ON WITH CALIFORNIA'S SENIOR
LEGISLATURE WHICH IS GREATLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL ONE CABINET
I WANT TO ADD.
ALL VETERANS DESERVE HOUSING THE
MATTER WHAT THEIR AGE BUT A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE
VETERANS ARE OLDER ADULTS THANK
YOU.
MANY MONTHS NOW AS A FRUITFUL
FUTURES PROJECT -- WE DO AN
AWFUL LOT WITH WITH THE HOMELESS
DOWN ON THE RIVER BAD.
AND MARK AND FAMILY HOUSING
POTTER SLAIN WERE THEY CONVERT.
CONTAINERS FOR THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SQUARE FEET OF HOUSING WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS SET
THREE WITH THREE GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS HOWEVER WE DO NOT HAVE
AN OFFICIAL POSITION ON THIS
BILL WE WILL BE REACHING OUT TO
THE OFF THEIR TO GAIN SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL.
THANKS.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
[inaudible]
NONE.
THEN -- I'D LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND
AS FOR YOUR COMMENTS SENATOR
NOTHING AMISS CHURCHES TO
QUESTION I DID JUST ON THE
DISABLED OR VETERAN DEFINITION I
WAS JUST CURIOUS AS TO HOW YOU
DETERMINED -- OF AN OVERALL
COMBINED RATING FACTOR OF 50% AS
THRESHOLD.
OF QUALIFYING -- A QUALIFIER IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT'S
TRADITIONALLY USED BY.
CALVET OR A US TVA.
AS AS OPPOSED 240% OR 45% OR 30%
IF THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
STILL DISCUSSING WITH CAL THAT'S
AND AS WELL AS THE DOLLAR AMOUNT
FOR THIS PROGRAM AND AS SOON AS
WE HALF THAT -- WE WILL.
BOB PUT INTO AMENDED INTO THE
BILL.
IDEA I ENCOURAGE YOU. TO TO
THINK CAREFULLY ABOUT THAT I
DON'T HAVE A FEELING ONE WAY OR
THE OTHER I MEAN.
I HAVE GREAT RESPECT FOR WERE --
FOR ALL OF THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO
SERVE IN [inaudible]
IN.
VETERANS WHO ARE DISABLED -- BUT
MY UNDERSTANDING IS DISABILITY
RATINGS CAN VERY AND YOU CAN
HAVE A 10% RATING OR YOU CAN
HAVE A TWENTY OR 25% OR THIRTY
OR FORTY OR FIFTY AND SO -- I'D
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
SOME OBJECTIVE EVIDENCE WHEN WE
SET IT AT 50% AS OPPOSED. 240%
AS OPPOSED 230%.
BECAUSE WE WE HAVE.
YOU KNOW WINNERS AND LOSERS.
AND WE OUGHT TO HAVE A
JUSTIFICATION FOR DOING THAT ONE
WHAT WHAT SOME JUSTIFICATION THE
CAN BE ARTICULATED.
CLEARLY AMONG OUR OF VETERAN AND
DISABLED VETERAN COMMUNITY SO I
JUST ASK YOU TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS CAREFULLY WITH
CALVET AND IF THEY'RE LISTENING
I WOULD ASK THEM.
TO THINK ABOUT IT -- CLOSELY
THANK YOU MISTER.
AND MISS ROB AND WILL DEFINITELY
HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS I I'D
LIKE TO ADD A MORE THANK YOU FOR
COMING FORWARD THERE'S THERE'S
SOME FLAWS THAT NEED TO BE
CLEARED UP.
ONE THE CALVET PROGRAM DOESN'T
GIVE RATINGS THE V. EIGHT IS THE
ONE WHO GIVES THE RATINGS AND
THEY GO FROM 10% ALL THE WAY TO
A 100%.
SO IF YOU MENTION 50%.
THEN THERE IT IS THERE'S YOUR
50% DISABILITY.
WHICH COULD BE THE THRESHOLD --
WHITE FIFTY VERSUS FORTY WERE.
EIGHTY YOU DON'T LOOK AT AT THAT --
SO YOU NEED TO DO A LITTLE MORE
INVESTIGATION SHE WERE YOUR
NUMBERS GOING TO BE THE AND THE
OTHER THING IS WE HAVE SECTION
EIGHT PROGRAM.
IN THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES AS
YOU KNOW SECTION.
EIGHT THIS WOULD UP PERHAPS MERE
SECTION EIGHT IT MIGHT LOOK INTO
THAT BECAUSE IT IT IT'S THE
SUBSIDY THAT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
I WOULD THINK. TO HELP VETERANS --
THAT NEED HELP.
WITH SUBSIDIZED RENT SO -- UNDER
THE SECTION EIGHT PROGRAM
[inaudible]
THERE'S A THE THE INDIVIDUAL
HYPOTHETICALLY MIGHT PAY A TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS AND THE SUBSIDY
WOULD BE A THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
PAY TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLAR MONTH
RANT.
ABOUT APARTMENT -- SO IF IF YOU
LOOK AT WHAT THE SECTION EIGHT
IS YOU MIGHT MERE THAT BECAUSE
OTHERWISE YOU WON'T BE ABLE.
TO JUSTIFY RECEIVING THE MONEY
FROM THE CAL BAT.
YOU YOU NEED TO HAVE SOME
PARAMETERS SO CLOSER TO I WOULD
RECOMMEND -- BUT I WILL -- GO
FORWARD WITH THE BILL AND AND
CERTAINLY BACK IT.
BUT YOU NEED TO MAKE SOME
AMENDMENTS THERE TO THAT TOTAL
WHEN HE GETS INTO FINANCIAL
YOU'LL BE ABLE.
TO HAVE SOMETHING THERE THAT IT
MERE SECTION EIGHT AND THAT IF
IT IS 50% THERE YOU GO BECAUSE
SOMEONE IT HAS A RATING OVER 50%
STILL ABLE TO WORK.
THEY MAY HAVE SOME SOME
DISABILITIES AND SO ON IT ALSO
LOOK INTO THAT -- GENERADO OTHER
COMMENTS THAT.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE IN --
TAKE THE ROLE.
AND I JUST MAKES WE HAVE IN
COMMON IS CLOSED YET WELL FIRST
OF ALL THANK YOU SENATOR.
HIM AS TRIED TO LET OF COURSE
SENATE ARE TO LET UP I WILL
DEFINITELY CONTINUE WORK ON THE
BILL MAKE SURE THAT SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT YOU'VE EXPRESSED
RIGHT NOW I HAVE BEEN.
TAKING CARE OF BUT THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND I AM A PROUD MEMBER OF
A MILITARY FAMILY AND SO.
GLAD YOU TO CARRY THIS BILL SO
JUST ON BEHALF OF OUR VETERANS I
ASKS RESPECTFULLY FOR YOUR
ARRIVAL THANK YOU.
GOOD HOW FOR THE BOOK.
SB SEVEN TWENTY FIVE TO PASS BUT
FIRST RE REFER RE REFER TO
PREPARATIONS ARCHULETA HI
ACTUALLY I GROWTH [inaudible]
THE TITLE [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
ROTH.
ROTH AYE NUMBER.
WILK.
ALL THAT OPEN OKAY WE'LL HOLD IT
OPEN BE REGULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR SUPPORTING OUR
VETERANS [inaudible]
OKAY -- NEXT UP IS SENATOR
GLAZIER.
CENTER GLAZER YOU HAVE SENATE
BILL -- SIX FOUR FOUR GO HEAD
PRESENT YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN NICE
TO BE HERE IN FRONT OF YOUR
COMMITTEE.
THIS THIS LEGISLATION THAT'S
BEFORE YOU WOULD PROVIDE RENTAL
RELIEF.
BASED IN CALIFORNIA.
I REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF SECURITY
DEPOSIT SERVICE MEMBERS ARE
REQUIRED TO PAY TO MOVE INTO A
RENTAL UNIT.
PROHIBITS LANDLORDS FROM
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST SERVICE
MEMBERS.
ARRIVING TO PAY LESS SECURITY
DEPOSIT.
BUT THERE IS A LEGISLATION ALSO
BY SENATOR HILL SP.
TWO TO TWO THAT ENFORCES THIS
PER PRO THIS PROVISION.
PRIVATE BY PROHIBITING
DISCRIMINATION IN THE RENTAL
MARKET BASED ON VETERAN OR
MILITARY SERVICE SO.
IS A REMEDY TO THE CONCERN THAT
WAS RAISED IN THE ANALYSIS -- IN
REGARD TO THAT THAT ISSUE -- WE
DO HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS IN OUR
STATE IT MAKES A PARTICULARLY
DIFFICULT FOR SERVICE MEMBERS TO
AFFORD UP FRONT COST.
OF MOVING INTO A RENTAL UNIT IN
IN CALIFORNIA.
I WITH MILITARY BARRACKS
BECOMING SCARCER THE NEED FOR
SERVICE MEMBERS TO FIND HOUSING
IN THE COMMUNITY WHERE THEIR
STATION BECOMES MORE.
COMMON.
AND MORE NECESSARY.
NOW THOSE SERVICE MEMBERS
RECEIVE A BASIC ALLOWANCE FOR
HOUSING.
MANY SAY IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO
COVER THE UP FRONT COSTS THESE
OF THE UP FRONT COST OF RENTING
CALIFORNIA.
AND ALTHOUGH SERVICE MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA RECEIVE A LARGER
ALLOWANCE TO OR THE HIGHER COST
OF LIVING.
WHEN SERVICE MEMBERS FROM OTHER
STATES MOVED T CALIFORNIA?
WE HAVE A LOT OF EXAMPLES OF
THAT.
IT OFTEN TAKES MONTHS FOR THE
INCREASE IN THE ALLOWANCE TO
KICK IN.
SERVICE MEMBERS RESORT TO LOANS
IN FACT THAT THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE -- LAST WEEK WE HAD
SOME SERVICE MEMBERS COME IN AND
TALK ABOUT THAT THEY RESORT TO
LOANS.
OTHER FORM OF CREDIT TO PAY
THEIR SECURITY DEPOSIT FIRST
MONTH'S RENT AND THIS
LEGISLATION ADDRESSES THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE.
FURTHER MORE SERVICE MEMBERS
HAVE A HIGHER STANDARD OF
CONDUCT IT THEY MUST COMPLY WITH
IN THEIR PERSONAL LIVES THAN
CIVILIANS.
I KNOW MANY OF YOU KNOW THAT IF
THEY DO NOT MEET THE STANDARD
THEY MAY BE REPRIMANDD BY THEIR
COMMANDING OFFICER OR THE
MILITARY. FOR EXAMPLE SERVICE
MEMBERS ARE REQUIRED TO MEET ALL
THEIR FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS EVEN
RENTAL CONTRACT.
IF THEY DO NOT THEY CAN BE
REPRIMANDED BY THEIR COMMANDING
OFFICER OR A MILITARY COURT THEY
COULD BE DEMOTED.
HAVE RESTRICTIONS PLACED ON THEM
OR EVEN DISCHARGED FROM THE
MILITARY SERVICE.
THESE PROVISIONS PROVIDE A
HIGHER STANDARD FOR SERVICE
MEMBERS TO MEET.
THEIR FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS MORE
THAN ANYBODY ELSE.
THIS BILL SUPPORTED BY SEVERAL
VETERANS GROUPS INCLUDING
AMERICAN GI FORUM AND THAT'S
CALIFORNIA SO SHE XIN VETERANS
SERVICE AGENCIES.
WHEN YOUR TESTIMONY FROM SOME OF
THE REPS AND JUST MOMENT WITHOUT
A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EITHER?
THANK YOU.
IF YOU'RE MEMBERS MY NAME IS SET
THREE WITH THREE GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS REPRESENTING AMERICAN
GI FORM OF CALIFORNIA AND VETS
DEPARTMENT OF CALIFORNIA.
AND CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDERS
VETERANS COUNCIL WHICH IS
COMPRISED TWENTY TWO VETERAN
ORGANIZATIONS.
SB SIX FOUR FOUR WOULD REDUCE
THE AMOUNT OF SECURITY DEPOSIT
SECURITY DEPOSIT SERVICE MEMBERS
HAVE TO PAY. FOR RENTAL UNITS BY
ONE MONTH.
THE MILITARY ORGANIZATIONS THAT
REPRESENT BELIEVE THAT THE BRAVE
MEN AND WOMEN WHO SERVE OUR
COMMUNITY OUR COUNTRY.
ARE BASED IN CALIFORNIA.
OUR YOUR HIGHEST CONSIDERATION
FOR THE RENTAL RELIEF SB SIX
FOUR FOUR PROVIDES.
WHAT IS MOST DIFFICULT FOR
SERVICE MEMBERS?
AND THEIR FAMILIES IS TO AND TO
ENTER IS THE STRESSFUL PROCESS
OF FINDING HOUSING IN A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME.
SERVE MEMBERS MUST HAVE SOME
KIND OF RELIEF I AM UNAWARE OF
ANY OTHER PROFESSION.
WHERE IF YOU DO NOT RELOCATE?
TO WHERE YOU ARE TOLD TO
RELOCATE.
YOU COULD LOSE YOUR JOB SB SIX
FOUR FOUR IS A FAIR AND
NECESSARY APPROACHED MITIGATING
AGAINST THE PROBLEMS.
SERVICE MEMBERS FACE.
WHEN THEY MOVED TO CALIFORNIA?
YOU FOR GO TO MILITARY JUSTICE
ALSO CODIFIES THE STANDARDS OF
CONDUCT THAT SERVICE MEMBERS
MUST FOLLOW.
WHICH PROVIDE SUFFICIENT
PROTECTION FOR LANDLORDS LOOKING
TO RECOUP AY LOST.
HAVE FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS ARE
NOT MET SERVICE MEMBERS CAN FACE
A MYRIAD OF DISCIPLINE ACTION.
AS FAR AS DISCIPLINARY.
THEY CAN FACE -- THINGS SUCH AS
HALF MONTHS WAGE BEEN REMOVED
AND THE BILL AND YOUR PERSONAL
TIME BEING TAKEN AWAY WITH.
A ESTIMATED FORTY FIVE DAYS.
OF PUNISHMENT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YOUR ANYONE -- IN THE
ARTISTIC TO PORCHES BILL.
GREG HE'S ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION VETERANS
SERVICE AGE HE'S VERY HAPPY TO
BE SUPPORTING SB SIX FORTY FOUR
AND HAS THE SENATOR NOTED.
I CENTER HILLS SB TWO TWO TWO IS
ESSENTIALLY A COMPANION MEASURE.
TOGETHER BOTH OF THESE -- BILLS
PROTECT VETERANS WERE RELOCATED
TO CALIFORNIA AND ALSO DEALING
WITH THE VERY HIGH COST OF
HOUSING IN THE STATE THANK YOU
FOR GOOD THANK YOU.
IN GOTHAM CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL.
THIS BILL AND FRANKLY ALL THE
VETERANS IN CALIFORNIA DON'T
HELP WE CAN GET THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AMVETS DURING PLASTER VICE
COMMANDER WE SUPPORT.
YOU GOT IT THANK YOU.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION -- WE HAVE
SOMEONE AT THE BOAT OKAY.
YEAH IT DOT JUST.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JENNIFER STACK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS.
THERE HASN'T OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON SB.
SIX FORTY FOUR THE NOT MEASURE
SEVERELY LIMITS THE ABILITY OF
SMALL PROPERTY OWNERS TO RECOUP
LOSSES RESULTING FROM DAMAGE
DONE TO A PROPERTY BY A TENANT.
CURRENTLY TWENTY FOUR STATES
INCLUDING NEW YORK ALLOW RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNERS TO ASK FOR A
SECURITY DEPOSIT FOR A
RESIDENTIAL RENTAL PROPERTY IN.
ANY AMOUNT THEY CHOOSE IN SHARP
CONTRAST CALIFORNIA HAS A
STATUTORY LIMIT PLACED -- IN
PLACE THAT RESTRICTS THE
SECURITY DEPOSIT AMOUNT THAT MAY
BE COLLECTED ON A PROPERTY OWNER.
SB SIX FORTY FOUR ALTERS THAT
RESTRICTION BY TO DRAMATICALLY
REDUCING THE SECURITY DEPOSIT.
AMOUNT THAT MAY BE COLLECTED
FROM A MILITARY PERSONNEL AS
WELL AS FROM THEIR SPOUSE
PARENTS DOMESTIC PARTNERS
INDEPENDENCE.
UNFORTUNATELY THE DRASTIC
REDUCTION WILL HURT SMALL
LANDLORDS AS THEY LACKED THE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES NECESSARY TO
MAKE REPAIRS.
OUT OF POCKET TO UNITS DAMAGED
BY TENANTS THEY'RE ALSO LESS
LIKELY TO CONTACT A UNIT
COMMANDER TO MAKE A CIVIL
COMPLAINT.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT SB
SIX FORTY FOUR BE AMENDED TO
EXEMPT SMALL LANDLORDS OWN
PROPERTIES WITH FIFTEEN UNITS
ARE LESS.
AS THE BILL COMPRISES
COMPROMISES THEIR ABILITY TO
RECOUP LOSSES RESULTING FROM
DAMAGE DONE TO THE PROPERTY BY A
TENANT. FOR THESE REASONS THERE
MUST OPPOSE SB SIX FORTY FOUR
UNTIL IT IS AMENDED TO EXEMPT
THESE SMALL MOM AND POP RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNERS.
WITH FIFTEEN UNITS ALAS
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PAT RAN
WITH THEIR AND READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL FOR
THE SAME REASONS THAT -- CA ARE
IS SUPPOSED -- 80% OF OUR
MEMBERS -- OWN UNIT OF THE
FIFTEEN UNITS ARE LESS -- SO
THAT AMENDMENT WOULD GO A LONG
WAY TO LEVY A OUR CONCERNS AND
WITH REGARD TO IN THIS IS FOR
ACTIVITY NOT VETERANS AND WITH
REGARD TO BEING ABLE TO CONTACT.
THE COMMANDING OFFICER IF -- THE
ACTIVE DUTY MILITARY -- RENTER --
DOESN'T PAY RAN TERROR IS
VIOLATING THE LEASE -- THIS
LEGISLATURE PASSED I BELIEVE
LAST YEAR A BILL.
THAT PROHIBITS.
LANDLORDS AND PROPERTY OWNERS
FROM CONTACTING THE COMMANDING
OFFICER OF THAT -- RENTER UNLESS
THEY HAVE WRITTEN PERMISSION
FROM -- BUT THAT RENTER TO DO SO
SO -- FOR THOSE REASONS
UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO OPPOSE THE BILL -- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
MAYBE THE MAYBE THE AUTHOR COULD
CLARIFY.
SO THE THE PROVISION THAT
PROHIBITS LANDLORDS FROM
DEMANDING RECEIVING SECURITY
FROM A MILITARY [inaudible]
SERVICE MEMBER. FOR THEIR SPOUSE
OR DOMESTIC PARTNER DEPENDENT
ARE THOSE DOES IT.
DOES IT SUGGEST THAT THOSE
PEOPLE ARE LIVING IN THE SAME
HOUSEHOLD IS THAT THE ISSUE.
OR IF MY DEPENDENT HAS A
SEPARATE RENTAL UNIT DOES THE
PROVISIONS APPLY IN THAT CASE AS
WELL.
WELL I'M NOT SURE I UNDERSTAND
YOUR QUESTION THAT THIS BILL
WOULD ONLY APPLY TO THE SERVICE
MEMBER AND IMMEDIATE MEMBERS OF
THEIR FAMILY.
IN THE SAME UNIT IN THE SAME
BOAT RENTAL YOU CORRECT.
SO IN THE MILITARY MEMBER.
IS NOT THE IS NOT THE SIGNATORY
ON THE LEASE BUT RATHER THE THE
PARENT IS IN THE MILITARY
MEMBERS LIVING WITH A PARENT IN
THE SAME APARTMENT.
THESE PROVISIONS WITH A PLAN
THAT LAYS OUT THE YOU KNOW THE
THE SERVICE MEMBER HAS TO
DISCUSS.
MILITARY STATUS UPON RENTAL OF
THE UNIT OR ELSE NONE OF THE
PROVISIONS REALLY WOULD COME
INTO.
PLAY BECAUSE THIS IS ABOUT A
SECURITY DEPOSIT.
SO IT'S ONLY ABOUT WHAT THEY PUT
IN ONE MONTH SECURITY POSITIVE
TWO MONTHS SECURE DEPOSIT
DEPENDING ON THE UNIT -- THERE'S
PROVISIONS BASED ON WHETHER ITS
IT'S IT'S GOT STUFF AND IT SURE
DOES -- SO THAT'S THE ONLY THING
THAT THIS THIS MEASURE TEMPS TO
DEAL WITH IS THAT SECURITY
DEPOSIT BUT DOWN AT THE START --
AND IT ONLY WAY THIS BILL GOES
INTO EFFECT.
IS IF THIS.
THAT IDENTIFIES THEMSELVES AS AT
BEING AN ACTIVE MILITARY STATUS.
WELL THERE IS A IS A QUESTION
CENTERS BECAUSE OF THE COMMENTS
OF THE OPPONENTS HERE I GATHER
THEY MADE THE COMMENT BECAUSE OF
THEY PERCEIVE THE BILL APPLYING
TO A SITUATION WHERE A DEFENDANT
OF A MILITARY MEMBER COMES IN
ATTEMPTS TO RENT.
AND THEY'RE NOT PERMITTED IN
THAT CIRCUMSTANCE FROM.
FROM RECEIVING THE SAME SECURITY
DEPOSIT THAT THEY WOULD BE
ALLOWED TO RECEIVE FROM ANY
OTHER NON MILITARY.
TENDED IN THE STATE SO IF YOU
JUST TAKE A LOOK AT THAT I'M
HAPPY TO I AM NOT THE BILL BY I
INTERPRETED THAT THE COMMON
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENTLY THAT IT WAS
ABOUT.
THE ABILITY -- TO IF THE ACTIVE
DUTY SERVICE MEMBER -- IN -- HAD
DAMAGES IN EXCESS OF THE TO
POSIT THAT ONE MONTH'S DEPOSIT
IN MOST CASES.
THAT THE IT WAS ABOUT THE
RECOURSE THAT THAT OUT LANDLORDS
MIGHT HAVE WITH THEIR COMMANDING
OFFICER.
AND THAT THAT THEY REFERENCE A
PROVISION THAT -- THAT WITHOUT
WRITTEN CONSENT THEY COULD NOT
CONTACT THE COMMANDING OFFICER
THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT I HEARD
THERE.
IN THAT PARTICULAR CASE -- I'M
OPEN TO THE SUGGESTION OF
PROVIDING THAT THAT REQUIRING
THAT WRITTEN AUTHORIZATION UPON
RENTAL OF THE UNIT.
A LOOK AT NO ONE WANTS TO HAVE --
LANDLORD BE THAT TIME DRY THAT'S
NO ONE'S INTEREST HERE.
IT'S A IT'S PARAGRAPH IT'S
SECTION [inaudible] TO I AM
DOING THIS RIGHT [inaudible]
HE TWO IS THE IS IS WHERE THERE.
IS WHERE THEY'RE ISSUE.
LIES I THINK SO IF YOU JUST TAKE
A LOOK AT THAT FIVE MOVE THE
BILL SO I DON'T WANT TO BELABOR
TIS.
SENATE ROTH WITH YOUR PERMISSION
I'M I WOULD LIKE TO AGREE WITH
YOU THAT IS OE OF OUR CONCERNS%
THAT.
THE THE BILL ISN'T BIG US IT
ALMOST REACHES IF IT'S SEPARATED
AND SO THAT JUST BY PROXY OF
BEING RELATED TO MILITARY
PERSONNEL YOU COULD.
APPLY TO HAVE THE REDUCTION
WHETHER THEY LIVE WITH YOU OR
NOT I GATHER THIS THAT THE
CENTERS ATTENTION ITSELF
[inaudible]
CLEAR THAT.
THERE WAS CHAIR.
COMMON AS WELL WE WANT TO MAKE
THIS IS AS A BUSINESS FRIENDLY.
AS VETERAN FRIENDLY WEEKS
POSSIBLY COULD.
AND YOU HAD MENTIONED FIFTEEN
UNITS AND BELOW IS MY POP.
THING -- BUT THE BILL DOES SAY
EXCESSIVE -- AMOUNT OF SECURITY
DEPOSIT AND THAT'S THAT'S A
QUESTION THAT THE MILITARY IS
ALWAYS CONCERNED ABOUT.
THAT SOMEONE.
ANY LANDLORD REGARDLESS OF THE
NUMBER OF UNITS -- ASK FOR A
DODGE PURITY DEPOSIT THAT HIS EX
IN EXCESS.
OF THAT'S A QUESTION IS IT ONE
MONTH DID YOU FIND EXCESSIVE.
WHAT WOULD BE EXCESSIVE
[inaudible]
AND AT SUCH A GOOD QUESTION AND
THE ORIGINS OF THIS BILL CAME
FROM THE COMMANDER IF THAT CAN'T
PARK IN MY DISTRICT.
WHO HAS THAT -- OBVIOUSLY ACTIVE
DUTY MILITARY.
SERVING ON HER FACE AND NECK AND
AS VERY WELL AWARE OF THE
EXPERIENCES THEY WERE FACING IN
TERMS OF THIS UPFRONT COSTS.
THIS BILL REDUCES THAT
OBLIGATION IN MOST CASES FROM
TWO MONTHS OF THE SECURITY
DEPOSIT.
TO ONE SO THERE IS STILL
SECURITY DEPOSIT PLACE.
BUT IT'S THE SECOND MONTH IT'S
CAUSING THE FINANCIAL CHALLENGES --
THAT THE BILL TRY SO AMENDMENT
READ.
THAT THAT THE DEMAND IN EXCESS
OF ONE MONTH AS A DEPOSIT.
THEN YOU HAVE.
SOMETHING THAT'S REASONABLE
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT EXCEEDING.
SOMEONE WERE ASKING FOR TWO OR
THREE MUCH DEPOSIT AT LEAST THE
LANDLORD KNOWS THAT HE HAS.
THE ABILITY TO TO RECEIVE A
DEPOSIT BUT NOT IN EXCESS F OF
A MONTH.
THAT MIGHT BE A POSSIBILITY.
THE OTHER IS THE FACT THAT.
THAT THE UNIT MUST BE OCCUPIED
BY THE FAMILY.
OF THE ACTIVE DUTY MEMBER.
AND ALSO THAT HE GIVES
PERMISSION. TO ALLOW HIS
COMMANDING OFFICER TO BE
NOTIFIED IN THE EVENT HE DOESN'T.
PAY THE RENT.
I THINK THAT WOULD.
THAT WOULD TAKE CARE OF SOME OF
THE ISSUE BECAUSE THE OPPOSITION
SAYS.
THAT IF I'M GOING TO DO THIS --
WHAT WE DO FOR MAY WELL IF YOU
DO THIS YOU HAVE ACCESS TO MY
COMMANDING OFFICER AND IF YOU?
DON'T -- REQUIRED TWO OR THREE
MONTHS.
OF DEPOSIT THEN YOU CAN CALL MY
COMMANDING OFFICER AND SHOW IN
MY IN LINE THE SENATOR.
WITH WITH AN AMENDMENT THAT YOU
THINK YOU CAN PUT TOGETHER ON
THAT YEAH SO I'M I AND I I I
COULD CERTAINLY COMMITTED TO
CLEARING UP THIS ISSUE THAT IT'S
REALLY IS ABOUT THE HE OR SHE
ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE MEMBER.
WE'RE TRYING TO AND TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THOSE WHO MAY BE LIVING
WITH THAT ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE
NUMBER -- THE ACTIVE DUTY
SERVICE MEMBER AND FAMILY THAT'S
RIGHT THAT THAT IS THAT'S WHAT
IT SAID IT TEMPTING TO ADDRESS
IF THAT'S NOT CLEAR IN TE BILL
HAPPY.
TO YEAH THE TO CLEAR THAT UP --
THAT YES WE ARE SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE OF WHETHER
OR NOT THE REQUIREMENT OF A
SECOND MONTH OR THIRD MONTH IS
REQUIRED WE'D LIKE IT TO BE --
ALL ONE MONTH -- IN REGARD TO AN
UNFURNISHED UNIT IN TWO MONTHS
IN REGARD -- TO FURNISHED UNIT.
SO.
THAT THAT I THINK IT'S CLEAR IN
THE BILL AND I AND THAT GOT MY
ATTENTION AND I DON'T AND I SEE
THAT.
MA'AM IT'S IT'S RIGHT HERE AND
THEN ABOUT -- NOT TO BE GREATER
pRENT.
SO I THINK THAT GIVES YOU THE
SECURITY DEPOSIT THAT THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR AND ACCESS TO
THE COMMANDING OFFICER IF YOU
CAN MAKE THOSE AMENDMENTS.
MR RESPECTFULLY ON OUR OUR BOARD
OF DIRECTORS LAW HAS LOOKED AT
THE ISSUE VERY CAREFULLY -- THAT
HAVING A SEPARATE STANDARD FOR
FOR MILITARY PERSONNEL BUT
PLACES ON OUR STANDARDS ON ON
OUR SMALL MOM AND POPS.
THEY DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE THE
SAME KIND OF OPERATING COSTS
THAT ARE LARGE PROPERTY OWNERS
DO.
ON WHICH IS WHY THEY'VE MADE THE
CONCESSIONS THAT -- IF WE COULD
REMOVE THE SMALL MOM AND POPS
THE FIFTEEN UNITS UNLESS WHICH
ARE NOT PROFESSIONALLY MANAGED --
THAT WOULD GO A LONG WAY --
TOWARDS US BEING ABLE TO REMOVE
OPPOSITION IN FACT IF WE WERE TO
EXEMPT THOSE PROPERTIES WE COULD
MOVE OPPOSITION IN ITS ENTIRETY
[inaudible]
YEAH.
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE STILL NOT IN
AGREEMENT AND AS THE OTHER
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION THE BILL
TESTIFIED 80% OF THEIR UNITS.
OUR LOW ARE FIFTEEN UNITS -- OUR
LAST SO WE HEARD THAT IT IS A
LARGE PART OF THE RENTAL MARKET
YEAH AND THAT'S NOT REALLY
TRYING TO GET IT HELPING THE
SERVICE MEMBERS THAT TERMS OF
WHAT THEY TYPICALLY INDOOR --
WHICH IS WHY WE HAVE WE STILL
NOT REALLY THE SAME PAGE ON THAT.
BUT IN THE LAST POINT THAT YOU
MADE ABOUT.
PERMISSION -- TO CONTACT THE
COMMANDING OFFICER I'M OPEN TO
TO TRY TO CRAFT AMENDMENTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
THAT WOULD BE GRANTED A GOOD
CASE CENTER IN THE REASON WE
HAVE TO MAKE THIS IS FRIENDLY AS
POSSIBLE BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE
THE HOUSING.
AVAILABLE TO AS MANY MILITARY
PERSONNEL AS POSSIBLE.
AND IF THERE'S FIVE OR SIX UNIT
SOMEWHERE OR TEN OR TWELVE AND
THERE'S VACANCIES WE WANT THOSE
VETERANS OR NOT THE BETTER BUT
THE MILITARY PERSONNEL TO HAVE A
AN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY AMONG
THEMSELVES. TO GO FOR IT AND IF
THEY HAVE PERMISSION TO TO SEE
THEIR COMMANDING OFFICER THE
LAND ORDER OR MANAGER ADDS THAT
I THINK THAT WILL TAKE CARE OF
THAT -- NOT TO EXCEED IT A
MONTH'S RENT I THINK THAT TAKES
CARE YOUR EXCESSIVE -- RENT THAT
WOULD NORMALLY BE CHARGE AND
IT'S THE FAMILY OF THE VETERANS
IN THOSE THREE ITEMS AND IF YOU
CAN MAKE HELL TO JUST ONCE.
I THINK TWO OR THREE IS NOT BAD.
THIS YEAR I THINK THAT WE CAN --
MAKE THAT ACCOMMODATION -- AS
YOU HAVE INDICATED.
LET ME JUST SAY THAT THE
ALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS HAS INCREDIBLE
PARTNERSHIP -- WITH OUR MILITARY
WITH VETERANS AND ACTIVE DUTY
SERVICE MEMBERS AND I I KNOW
THAT.
THEY COME HERE WITH THEIR
CONCERNS THAT -- DEEPLY FELT BUT
NOT OUT OF ANY ANY.
LACK OF WONDERFUL SUPPORT --
THAT WE GET FROM OUR REALTORS
LOCALLY AND CERTAINLY FROM THE
STATE'S OF WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
OUT THESE WILL TRY TO SEE IF WE
CAN WORK OUT THESE DIFFERENCES
WE DO HAVE A THE FUNDAMENTAL ONE
THAT WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN TO YET.
BUT ON THE ONES THAT YOU'VE
RAISED I THINK WE CAN FIND A
COMBINATION ON I BELIEVE TALK
AND I APPRECIATE.
EVERYONE WHO DOES OPEN THEIR
DOORS VETERANS AS WELL TO THANK
YOU FOR THAT.
IF THERE ARE NO OTHER COMMENTS --
IN I THINK WE THEY WOULDN'T
COVER THE BOTH THE WE ASK FOR
THE AND YOUR CLOSING COMMENTS I
THINK THAT THAT MADE THEM AND I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
TODAY AND AND FOR YOUR CONCERN
FOR OUR VETERANS AND ACTIVE DUTY
SERVICE MEMBERS.
GOOD -- CALL VOTE.
SENATE BILL SIX FOUR FOUR DO
PASS ARCHULETA YES IRELAND I
GROWTH -- TADO.
HOW DO I NIELSEN?
I'M ROTH.
I AM BURKE.
I WILK.
HI WILK AND THAT PATH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SO WE WILL SERVE.
CALL THE ROLL ON THAT ONE AND
AND THEN ONE OPEN AND THEN
EVERYTHING ELSE [inaudible]
OKAY -- ANNOUNCER US NOW THAT WE
HAVE.
MORE PEOPLE IN THE TO GO AHEAD
AND CALL STARTING WITH THE TOP
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
HOW ARE WE WAITING -- BUT WHERE
WE'VE GOT EVERYBODY.
THAT WAS LATER -- WESSEL HAS NOT
THE SHOWN UP.
THEY USUALLY ONE NO THAT WASN'T
CONTENT.
WITH HIS BILL WITH ON CONTENT SO
HE DOES COME IN OKAY.
SO WITH
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
A DO PASSED THE FIRST REFERRED
PREPARATION WITH RECOMMENDATION
CONSENT CAN GROWTH.
HER TITLE. FOR TITLE I AM BURKE.
I'M PROVIDE UP HALF THE SOUTH.
A SIMPLE THREE TWELVE TO PASS
THE FIRST REFER PERFORATIONS HER
TITLE.
I AMBER.
AMBER GUY THAT PASSES THEM.
SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY FORTY
PASSED THE FIRST READ REFER TO
PREPARATIONS ARE PRODUCT. FOR
TITLE I NUMBER.
NUMBER I THINK THAT ALL SEVENTH.
US SENATE BILL FORTY ONE HER
TITLE. FOR TITLE II NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I ALL SEVEN THAT PASSED
WITHOUT.
SENATE BILL.
FIVE SIXTY TWO THE PAST THAT
FIRST REFERRED PREPARATIONS FOR
TITLE.
THE TITLE I NUMBER.
AND I WILL.
LOOK AT ALL SEVEN PASSES OUT.
SENATE BILL.
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT HER TOP OF
FIRST YOU PASSED THE FIRST REFER
PREPARATIONS FOR TARA.
I NIELSEN NIELSEN I WILK. FOR
TITLE I NIELSEN NIELSEN I AM.
NUMBER I WILK.
LOOK I THAT SIX ZERO PASSES OUT.
HOW DO WE HANDLE [inaudible]
THE BATTLE.
THANK YOU EVERYONE